mes bien chers abonnés pardonnez moi car
j'ai péché oui j'ai péché car il a fallu
que je fasse marche arrière sur les
momies de nasca il a fallu que je retire
toutes mes vidéos sur les momies de nas
kg pêché par lâcheté après avoir reçu
des plaintes pour atteinte au copyright
bon qui ne sont en fait que de la
censure mais bon la raison officielle
c'est du copyright
j'ai reçu des plaintes pour atteinte au
copyright et comme youtube déconne pas
avec le copyright
si je supprimais pas toutes mes vidéos
des momies de nasca de la chaîne tout
mais des blocages et bas j'aurais fini
avec une chaîne fermé et évidemment je
veux pas que ma chaîne ferme come to you
tube heures qui se respecte donc
maintenant si vous voulez voir les
vidéos sur les mobiles dans ce cas il
faut aller sur le site d'irna ou
quelques unes d'entre elles ont été ré
au plo d au moins deux d'entre elles ont
été ré au plo d donc voilà je remercie
chaleureusement irna d'avoir remis ces
vidéos en ligne et aujourd'hui il va
falloir que je paye pour sa cinquième
étape de notre chemin de croix des
bonnes kg pénitence j'ai longtemps pensé
faire un épisode sur la lithothérapie et
puis ça n'a pas marché parce que j'ai
pas trouvé de bons articles sur la
lithothérapie par contre j'ai trouvé cet
article qui parle de l'utilisation d'os
fossilisés de tyrannosaurus rex pour
faire de l'homéopathie et là je me suis
dit ça y est j'ai trouvé la perle rare
là les gens se font marabouté à la grand
coup de tyrannosaurus rex
alors pourquoi je dis marabouté parce
que l'homéopathie ça ça n'a d'effet que
l'effet placebo finalement ce qui
finalement est exactement le même effet
qu'un maraboutage donc quand vous faites
de l'homéopathie vous faites marabouté
c'est la même chose c'est le même effet
kiss cool donc vous pouvez vous faire
marabouté un coup de tyrannosaurus rex
et moi je trouve ça complètement classe
2 problème avec le fait de traiter
justement l'utilisation du tyrannosaurus
rex en homéopathie comme un sujet des
bonnes kg pénitence premièrement j'en
avais envie et nous savons tous que des
bonnes kg pénitence n'est pas fait pour
m'amuser c'est fait pour que j'en chie
et deuxièmement et bien finalement ils
disent pas que des conneries sur cette
page
au contraire voilà vous enfin je le fais
défiler rapidement mais vous avez
l'adresse du lien juste au dessus vous
pouvez allez voir ils disent pas de la
merde en fait ça c'est c'est quand même
méchant quoi bon alors vous avez la
catégorie mythes et légendes mais au
finalement ils disent finalement il
ces huit idée préconçue sur les
dinosaures qui il des bugs efficacement
au final ou pas si mal que ça voilà l
utilisation en homéopathie qui aurait
été le côté marrant du truc
au final vous voyez c'est assez limité
donc voilà j'aurais bien aimé apprendre
qu'on utilisait les t-rex pour qu'on
utilise et l'os de t-rex pour traiter
les cancers etc
mais ce n'est pas le cas il en parle pas
ici donc voilà on ne peut pas traiter
l'utilisation du t-rex en homéopathie
pour ceux des bonnes kg pénitence parce
que de toute façon et je le répète ça
m'aurait amusé et des bonnes kg
pénitence c'est fait pour en chier alors
j'ai sélectionné un article mesdames et
messieurs auger pas envie de lire mais
alors pas du tout pas du tout déjà
regardé cette peu et un de plus voilà
c'est un article qui était hyper long et
et et surtout faut voir ce site science
fait et histoire titre de l'article
un dinosaure intelligent un dinosaure
intelligent alors au début on voit le
trot donc ça a l'air d'aller une petite
reconstruction d'un dinosaure à plumes
ça a l'air d'aller
après on arrive évidemment aux
dinosaures anthropoïdes de russell 1 2
qui avait été fait pour une exposition
juste comme ça c'était un essai
finalement 2 de sciences spéculative
donc on en arrive là donc ça déjà bon ça
a été des bunkers mille et une fois
d'ailleurs si vous voulez le voir il
agit quant aux raptor qui en a parlé
donc si je tape gigan tôt raptor
dinosaures intelligent j'imagine que je
vais tomber dessus
je crois que c'est dit dit jean louis
louis et le troodon alors est-ce que
c'est dans celui là tu râles a dit diana
alors il a fait le début une cage avec
alexis rastier qui est un très bon
youtuber paléontologues cessé de la
qualité vous pouvez vous pouvez aller le
voir et j'essaie de retrouver le passage
où il en parle parce qu'il ya aussi
toute une discussion évidemment sur
l'anthropomorphisme de cette
reconstruction
voilà c'est ici donc il ya toute une
discussion sur l'anthropomorphisme de
cette reconstruction puisque c'est enfin
je veux dire
il imagine un animal intelligent donc
forcément ça ressemble à un humain voilà
on peut pas être intelligent et ne pas
ressembler à un humain et voilà le trou
dont c'était trop intelligent donc voilà
si vous vous posiez des questions sur la
véracité de cette reconstruction si vous
en avez déjà entendu parler de cette
chose là bas vous pouvez aller voir
d'ores et déjà la vidéo de gigue
entourent appstore mais voilà et quand
vous descendez surtout vous scrollé cet
article et voilà les crânes déformés ou
lala et les fait crouler le gros fake
voilà là et les terres la tératologie
donc ça c'est une maladie ça faut
arrêter de prendre ça pour des
extraterrestres et des maladies ça
voilà et évidemment les égyptiens parce
qu'on ne fait pas de bonnes pseudo
science sans une grosse spéculations sur
les égyptiens donc vous voyez ça va être
très douloureux ça va être très très
douloureux et vous sentez là que ça va
descendre
petit à petit la le niveau il va chuter
petit à petit au fur et à mesure de la
lecture et le site s'appelle science
fait et histoire science fait histoire
nous mîmes son nom à l'épreuve comme
diraient les spartiates science fait
histoire dont je rappelle les deux
principes de damon kg pénitence
premièrement faut que ça fasse pas
plaisir du tout à lire et deuxièmement
il faut qu'on ait moins de popularité
que ce qu'on décide de des banques est
donc là pour le coup il à 2800 abonnés
sur sachez enfin sur son sur sa page
youtube je sais pas combien il ya eu de
lecture sur cette page c'est écrit nulle
part mais on je sais que sur son compte
facebook il a plus d'abonnés que nous il
ya plus de followers donc donc donc donc
bye bye bas on va s'y mettre
on va s'y mettre lentement mais sûrement
c'est parti pour un dinosaure
intelligent alléluia un dinosaure
intelligent d'être aux dons voyez le
l'intelligence qui brille dans leurs
yeux
on a découvert dans les film jurassic
park le velociraptor à l'époque était
considéré comme le plus intelligent de
tous les dinosaures ayant existé et les
films le montre oui parce que maintenant
les films font office de démonstration
alors il le montre telle qu'on
l'imaginait à l'époque des films
la réalité a fait que les velociraptor
ne ressembl ait finalement pas du tout à
ceux des films puisque et puis ce qu'ils
étaient entièrement recouvert de plumes
est plus petit que ceux des films bien
que certaines variétés trouvé en utah et
montana entre autres soit plus grande
que celle des films bon il fait
référence à l'ugta raptor mais aussi ses
voilà toujours confusion entre
velociraptor l'espèce et velociraptor la
grande famille qui est en fait la
famille des drôme et aux au rider mais
bon admettons voilà c'est pas c'est pas
un article qui est fait pour parler de
dinosaures 1
voilà mais aussi qu'ils se sont a priori
est un avant la date estimée des
dinosaures les velociraptor ont vécu de
-80 à moins 70 millions d'années avant
maintenant alors ça veut dire quoi ça
avant maintenant alors que ces 5
millions d'années plus tard environ que
les gros dinosaures semble avoir disparu
oui bah si tu prends l'espèce
velociraptor c'est c'est normal c'est
pas les drom et aux heures les drom et
aux orres se sont éteints il ya 65
millions d'années mais ce sujet ne remet
pas d'ailleurs la théorie de l'évolution
de darwin en cause fondamentalement mais
font se poser plutôt des questions sur
le term evolution ah ça y est on touche
à darwin une adaptation comme celle
subie à priori par les dinosaures et les
mutants en petit oiseau semblant plutôt
être une régression pour certains plutôt
qu'une évolution popopo alors le term
evolution déjà une et veut définir le
terme évolution en commençant par une
adaptation
déjà tu as tout perdu tu as tout perdu
l'évolution c'est pas que l'adaptation
il ya la dérive génétique il ya
l'évolution neutre donc déjà
l'adaptation un non non non on peut
avoir une évolution totalement non
adaptative et surtout surtout le fait
qu'il commence directement par
adaptation fait qu'on va parler de
progrès progrès dinosaures intelligent
voilà vous avez déjà tout compris le mec
n'a donc pas compris le term evolution
je leur envoie quasiment toutes là toute
la vidéographie jill antho raptor à ce
sujet parce que là il ya vraiment trop à
dire donc une adaptation comme celle
subie à priori par les dinosaures et les
mutants en petits oiseaux semblent
plutôt une régression pour certains
plutôt qu'une évolution une ré une
régression quand on évolue en oiseaux
ils ont put inde appris à voler il te
faut quoi pour que ton évolution soit
pas une régression non mais déjà déjà le
terme régression impliquer une flèche
bleue avec un sommet à l'évolution donc
on régresse quand on va à la base et on
progresse quand on va au sommet et déjà
ça c'est faux donc déjà dire qu'il ya
une régression c'est de la merde mais en
plus dire que passer d'un dinosaure à un
oiseau c'est une régression c'est non
les oiseaux ont des tas de choses que
les dinosaures n'ont pas donc c'est pas
une régression c'est pas parce qu'ils
sont petits d'ailleurs les trop aux dons
était petit je veux dire alors quel est
le problème
bref sauf sauf si on considère la perte
de certains gros avantage de prédateurs
contre le fait de pouvoir voler par
exemple soient considérables comme une
évolution positive et non négative une
évolution négative et c'est un peu comme
comme l'être humain où l'homo sapiens
qui semble bien née troll c'est comme
j'ai du mal
c'est un peu comme l'être humain où
l'homo sapiens qui semble être le tout
dernier représentant d'une race plus
diversifiée auparavant ou d'une race
l'emploi du mot race j'adore je vais pas
commenter là dessus une race diversifier
alors parles-tu des grands singes très
cher ami
donc oui si tu parles des grands singes
l'être humain appartient
attaques sont qui a été beaucoup plus
diversifiée auparavant il y avait des
centaines d espèce de grands singes
maintenant il y en a huit je crois dont
l'être humain
à la limite les homininés ont été très
diversifiée à une époque on a eu
beaucoup d'espèces de parents -trop-
d'australopithèques mais deux races non
des espèces éventuellement en fait
peut-on vraiment considérer qu'il a
évolué et évoluent toujours oui on peut
considérer qu'il évolue toujours tout
simplement parce que le seul moyen de
pas évolué c'est d'arrêter de se
reproduire
ou alors de se cloner il ya qu un seul
moyen d'arrêter l'évolution c'est ça le
clonage alors qu'il est prouvé que sa
capacité cervicales son cerveau diminue
de plus en plus au fur et à mesure du
temps me vous me hui source de cette
information s'il vous plaît la capacité
du cerveau diminue au fur et à mesure du
temps non non non non elle à une
variabilité considérable mais en moyenne
constante donc c'est faux et qui semble
perdre de plus en plus de sa protection
naturelle contre les éléments dont le
soleil en perdant sa pilosité notamment
bon et puis zut en fait les films et les
archéologues de l'époque ont un peu
mélangé les genres et les âges
bon bah c'est pas les seuls 10 dont les
films ont un peu mélangé les or les gens
et les âges les films oui mais les
archéologues n'ont déjà scellé
paléontologues si tu parles de
dinosaures jacky découvert dès 1854 l'un
des premiers dinosaures a avoir été
retrouvée en amérique du nord le troodon
correspond beaucoup plus aux petits
prédateurs intelligente des films de par
son intelligence
de par son apparence et intelligence et
il aurait vécu lui au moins jusqu'à la
fin des deux présumés d'extinction entre
75 et 65 millions d'années avant
maintenant avant maintenant [ __ ] c'est
une traduction de l'anglais un peu
brutal ce avant maintenant je le trouve
sais je sais pas de quel article il a
tiré sa de mais c'est une traduction ça
ça ressemble à une traduction brutale de
l'anglais quoi alors trop de dettes de
découverte allait finalement on va le
faire
trois sont nés là pour ça trop de date
de découverte
edge orange 84 à 66 millions d'années
bon ben voilà trop dense a l'air d'aller
et donc effectivement première
description première description en 1856
voilà donc bon c'est globalement ça
s'est globalement ça ouais 65 15 à 65
nonce apparemment ce maintenant ça a été
dit et 84 66 bref mais en même temps
c'est pas le coeur du sujet quelques
faits sur les dinosaures troodon aussi
appelé sténo nique aux orres pour les
dernières versions trouvait au canada
alors c'était noni causeur les dernières
versions découvert auquel déjà il met un
accent dessus c'est ça fait mal donc on
va enlever l'accent et puis on va
rajouter
eurus à la fin si on veut faire un peu
scientifique
donc quoi en fait c'était nonick aux
eaux russes c'est un synonyme de trop
donc iliad été découvert avant mille
mille neuf cent trente deux donc c'est
peut-être
ouais c'est peut-être les derniers
survivants des trop dont j'ai pas
vérifié mais en tout cas c'est c'est un
genre synonyme de trop dont en fait donc
trop dont prévaut à sténo ni cause aux
rustines stan honey cause aux russes
ayant certains certainement fini en au
maine du biome donc en on doute eux
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas assez de
matériel les troodon avait un cerveau
plus gros que la plupart des dinosaures
la caractéristique la plus notable du
trône en était sont exceptionnellement
grand cerveau qui était plus beaucoup
plus grands proportionnellement au reste
du corps par rapport à la matière
cérébrale de dinosaures de taille
comparable
selon une analyse les trop aux dons
avait un quotient dans ses valises à
sion à plusieurs niveaux un quotient
dans ses valises à sion à plusieurs
niveaux donc il disposait d'une capacité
d'analysé de l'environnement
exceptionnel surpassant celle de toutes
les autres espèces de l'époque et leur
permettant d'être dominant malgré leur
taille réduite et pourrait
éventuellement avoir évolué au niveau
humain de l'intelligence alors le
caution dans ses valises à sion mais là
on va décrire ce que c'est donc le
quotient dans ses valises à sion ou
coefficient dans ses valises à sion en
français c'est c'est une mesure de la
taille du cerveau par rapport au poids
en fait c'est la taille du cerveau
attendu
c'est la vraie taille du cerveau comparé
à la taille du cerveau attendu pour un
animal de poids comparable
c'est ça le coefficient dans ses valises
à sion et tout ce qu'on peut savoir à
partir de ce coefficient dans ses
valises à sion c'est est ce que le
cerveau est plus gros que prévu ou pas
parce que les capacités d analyse on les
déduit pas de la taille du cerveau à
l'âge
je vous renvoie à notre vidéo donc stop
science sur l'intelligence voilà
l'intelligence donc celle ci un la
petite vidéo avec la vignette homer
simpson
donc là on parle de la taille du cerveau
de comment la mesure et de ce qu'on peut
en dire
au final et non on peut pas en dire ça
en tout cas la capacité d' analyse de
l'environnement exceptionnel donc cette
idée là du trot dans ça nous vient de
jerry sonne sonne donc on va taper trop
dont gerry sonne brain donc d'une
analyse qui l'a fait dans les années 70
donc le sieur jerry sonne docteur jerry
sun qui est qui avait mesuré le cerveau
du trot aux dons dans les années 70
c'est en avait déduit qu'il avait un
relativement gros cerveau a écrit un
article plus récent dans pour la
encyclopedia en euros c'est rien de ce
qui a été publié quelque part dans les
années 2000
bon après il ya eu plusieurs éditions
comme vous pouvez le voir et en gros
dans cette danse est nouvelle dans cette
nouvelle édition
il nous parle du trot dont page 3 donc
il nous dit ici le volume du cerveau de
trop donc du mois de l'endocrâne de trop
dont c'est à dire le volume de la cavité
cérébrale du cerveau de du crâne de trop
aux dons est de 20 millilitres
ce qui est à peu près la moitié de ce
qui avait été suggéré dans les
précédentes publications donc le troodon
là les premières publications avait
doublé la taille finalement du cerveau
de trop dont déjà ça c'est important
alors comparé à sa taille de corps de 45
kg
un cerveau 2002 20 millilitres place
trop aux dons sur la
sur le haut de la variation des reptiles
vivants et en dessous des oiseaux donc
le trot dont il avait un cerveau qui
était exceptionnellement gros si on le
considère comme un reptile on va dire
mais qui n'était pas spécialement gros
du tout le considérant comme un le
considérant comme un comme un proche
parent des oiseaux or je le rappelle les
dinosaures sont plus proches parents des
oiseaux donc au final le trot dont il
n'avait pas du tout un gros cerveau quoi
il avait un cerveau qui était même
plutôt en dessous de la moyenne comparée
à ses proches parents actuels que sont
les oiseaux et pas les reptiles
justement donc donc trop dont il n'a pas
un si gros cerveau que ça au final donc
une capacité d analyse dans
l'environnement exceptionnel surpassant
celle de toutes les autres espèces
mouais bof bref mais en 1982 donc avant
que tout ceci soit publiée avant qu'on
réalise que le cerveau de trop dont la
taille du cerveau trop dont avait été
surestimé
en 1982 le paléo le paléontologue
canadien dellerie seul à spéculer ce qui
serait arrivé si trop aux dons avait
réussi à survivre à l'extinction qu'a t
il ya 65 millions d'années dans son
histoire contrefactuelle le tronc aux
dons a évolué sur deux jambes un reptile
intelligent à grands cerveaux avec de
grands yeux les pouces opposables
partiellement est 3 doigts à chaque main
bon alors déjà on va remettre les choses
en au point d'une les proches parents de
trous dont se sont pas éteints il ya 65
millions d'années ces sont les oiseaux
les drom et aux or c'est le groupe frère
donc c'est le plus proche parent est un
des oiseaux donc déjà et le tous les
dinosaures se sont pas éteints il ya 65
millions d'années il ya des proches
parents du trou dans qui ont survécu et
qui ont donné des animaux intelligents
comme les perroquets et les corbeaux 1
je le rappelle que les corbeaux sont
quand même capable de résoudre des
problèmes et les perroquets aussi sont
capables de résoudre des problèmes
ils ont donc une très grande
intelligence donc c'est un dinosaure
devait était devenu intelligent c'est un
dinosaure proche des drum et aux orres
étaient devenus intelligents et ne se
serait pas et à 65 millions d'années ça
aurait donné un perroquet et un corbeau
voilà alors le troodon a évolué sur deux
jambes je rappelle que les trop aux dons
suggérée par cette image sont déjà
habitées aide donc voilà il ya évolué
sur deux jambes non il était déjà
bipèdes
il avait un grand cerveau avec des
grands yeux bruns admettons et des
pouces opposables partiellement et trois
doigts sur chaque main à trois doigts
sur chaque main c'est pareil les avais
déjà et les pouces opposables
ils étaient déjà plus ou moins opposable
chez tous les drom et aux orres donc
pareil a rien de nouveau en soi donc
contrairement à la version de
l'évolution sur laquelle le moteur
serait le progrès pas le progrès à kaka
kaka le progrès contrairement à la
version de l'évolution selon laquelle le
moteur serait le progrès continu et
linéaire linéaire comme l'ont fort bien
expliqué stephen jay gould et davy drop
entre autres seul seule la malchance a
éliminé les dinosaures et leurs
semblables et pourtant ils dominaient
depuis plus de cent millions d'années le
monde vivant on a même postulé que le
sténo nique aux orres découvert au
canada en 1967 possédait des facultés
étonnante et que son cerveau était
anormalement développer d'autres petits
dinosaures bipèdes carnivores évolué
d'une manière très favorable vers
l'intelligence
il n'y a pas d'évolution vers
l'intelligence je veux dire à une
évolution vers l'intelligence comme si
toute évolution devait tendre vers
l'intelligence c'est tellement
anthropocentriste l'évolution ne va pas
vers l'intelligence elle va dans toutes
les directions et de temps en temps ça
prend la direction de l'intelligence
bref bernard werber
ah bah ça y est maintenant on se met à
citer bernard werber ou là je crains le
pire
parmi la foule des dinosaures divers qui
peuplaient la terre il ya 65 millions
d'années une espèce particulière marcher
sur deux pattes posséder notre taille et
un cerveau occupants pratiquement autant
la place que le nôtre le sténo nique aux
orres alors le stan honey causeur faut
arrêter d'utiliser ce mot c'est à
synonyme de trop donc c'est le troodon
et will marcher sur deux pattes parce
que de toute façon tous les [ __ ] de
théropodes marcher sur deux pattes il
avait notre taille non trop dont étaient
largement plus petit et son cerveau
occuper autant de place que le nôtre
alors je reviens à
je reviens à jerry sonne 20 millilitres
de cerveau donc sachant qu'à l'époque il
pensait qu'il faisait le double de ça
c'est à dire 40 millilitres on est très
très loin des on est très très loin de
l'homme l'a quand même l'homme
il a quand même un cerveau à coups de
1400 centimètres cubes alors attends
comment convertit les millilitres ben ça
fait vingt centimètres cubes
ça tombe bien l'aider millilitres donc
ça se ça se change directement
centimètres cubes
donc voilà qui est très voilà qui est
très très très sympa pour nous donc
voilà on a un cerveau qui à l'époque
faisait quarante centimètres cubes
enfin que dont on pensait qu'il faisait
quarante centimètres cube pour le
troodon comparé à 1400 centimètres cube
pour l'homme
faudrait voir à pas déconner non plus
hein donc non qu'occupe rend
pratiquement autant de place que le
nôtre non non et puis même ramené au
poids du corps je veux dire un homme
c'est un cerveau de 1400 centimètres
cube pour un poids de 70 kg en moyenne
le trot dont on part sur un poids qui
est la moitié de celui d'un homme en
gros 1 45 kg pour 1 trop de moyens avec
un cerveau qui est deux ordres de
grandeur plus petits dont on parle je le
redis on passe de 1400 à 40
donc même en divisant le poids par deux
ça vous amène pas à une proportion de
cerveau comparables
jamais jamais donc voilà pourquoi je
craignais le pire en lisant bien en
lisant que la prochaine citation était
de bernard werber
c'est parce que voilà c'est ainsi c'est
principalement un auteur de fiction
bernard werber
donc c'est pas exactement une référence
scientifique alors que notre ancêtre
mammifères ne ressemblait qu'à une
musaraigne lesté de nico d'or était
vraiment des animaux très évoluée ces
bibles très évolués l'évolution n'a pas
de sommet je le rappelle ces bipèdes aux
allures de kangourou à peau de lézard
avait les yeux en forme de soucoupe
capable de voir devant et derrière
avouons d'eux avouant que ce gadget nous
manque
grâce à une sensibilité occultes
extraordinaire il pouvait chasser même à
la tombée de la nuit ils possédaient des
griffes rétractables comme les chats de
griffes rétractables chez les trop
d'europe
bon dieu des griffes rétractables chez
les pros dont deux dinosaures
vous avez déjà vu des griffes
rétractables sur un oiseau ouais bah moi
pareil de longs doigts et delon orteils
aux capacités de préhension étonnante
alors pas les orteils non les noms l'ema
la limite je veux bien parce qu'ils
avaient à nos semis lunaire qui leur
permettait de fléchir le poignet d'une
façon extraordinaire ça je suis d'accord
il pouvait par exemple saisir un caillou
et le jeter eh ouais et ouais je sais
pas à quoi ça leur est servie mais ils
auraient pu les professeurs canadiens
d'aillerus elle est harcelée guînes
donc voilà dell dell il a le droit
d'avoir son prénom mais monsieur seguin
il n'a pas le droit
vous sentez aussi la traduction pareil
là qui ont étudié les sténo nique aux
hordes oncle et road ont arrêté de la
playstation y cause or c'est pas vrai ça
penser qu'il disposait d'une capacité d
analyse de l'environnement exceptionnel
surpassant celle de toutes les autres
espèces de l'époque et leur permettant
d'être dominant malgré leur taille
réduite alors les troodontidés je crois
pas qu'ils aient dominé quoi que ce soit
des troodontidés c'est une part assez
mineur delà de la biodiversité du
crétacé alors attends je vais aller voir
un on va aller voir la domination des
trouveront-ils et paléo biology database
et on va aller demander à la
paléobiologie database comment qu'ils
étaient dominants les trous dont idée
parce que là la domination des
troodontidés a pas de mal alors explore
paléo biology la tabelle donc outil très
pratique la paléontologie database que
j'utilise presque systématiquement
maintenant vous le savez donc trop aux
dons ty et voilà les trop aux dons innés
et donc paléobiologie vatable database
va nous montrer ou et éléctro d'anti des
donc voyez ici donc vous avez des
troodontidés jusque dans
jusqu'à jusqu'en alaska est sur cette
ligne là qui étaient les grandes plaines
d'amérique du nord
et vous avez quelques trop haute idée en
asie et quelques spots ici et là en
europe mais alors l'afrique l'amérique
du sud l'australie la sibérie 03 90 il
est donc pour une espèce dominante pas
pour un point attaques sont dominants
devrais-je dire on est un peu à la
ramasse mais ça c'est la famille des
troodontidés maintenant trop dont lui
même
donc c'était noni causeur pour le
monsieur trop dont lui même le genre
trop dont il n'est connu qu'en amérique
du nord et une petite partie de
l'amérique du nord et en alaska
donc voilà on n'est pas exactement sur
de l'espèce qui a envahi le monde et qui
est dominante
pas du tout même en fait donc tu
confonds dinosaures et road on la tue ou
du moins tu mélanges dinosaures et road
ont allègrement histoire de brouiller
les pistes et d'arriver là où tu veux en
venir à ce que l'aide de dinosaures
trouvé de sténo ni causeur trouvait dans
l'alberta en 1967 confirme que ces
reptiles avait des zones d'activité
cérébrale très différente des autres
dinosaures comme nous ils avaient le
cervelet et le bulbe rachidien
anormalement développés alors non pas du
tout ben alors voyons voir cerveau
humain cerveau humain image alors un
cerveau humain on va voir voilà donc le
cerveau humain je vous le montre ici on
va faire un petit zoom sera pas besoin
d'être très détaillé le cerveau humain
ce qui le rend intelligent c'est son
néocortex c'est-à-dire toute cette
partie énorme l'appli c'est que vous
voyez là le cervelet ici et le bulbe
rachidien
ici ils sont pas spécialement très
développé vous pouvez voir qu'ils sont
beaucoup plus petits que le néocortex et
le cervelet le bulbe rachidien
basiquement c'est
le cervelet sa contrôler la locomotion
et le bulbe rachidien
c'est les réflexes donc c'est pas du
tout ce qui vous rend intelligent c'est
pas là que ça se passe l'intelligence
pas du tout donc le cervelet le bulbe
rachidien c zéro pour évaluer
l'intelligence même si on pouvait
évaluer l'intelligence de façon
anatomique ce qui est impossible mais
bon bref c'est pas au niveau du cervelet
du bulbe rachidien que ça se passerait
il pouvait comprendre réfléchir mais
trop doux au point une stratégie de
chasse même en groupe spéculation ron
spéculation ouais bien sûr par son
allure générale le style denis coderre
ressemblait davantage à un kangourou
comparer les dinosaures kangourou c'est
peut-être le truc le moins cons que j'ai
lu jusqu'à présent mais selon russell et
seguin s'il j'avais j'aime bien le mot
seguin ça me fait penser à une chèvre
bref si les dinosaures n'avait pas
disparu ce serait plus probablement cet
animal qui aurait développé la vie
sociale et la technologie mais il n'y a
pas de finalité dans l'évolution ya pas
un animal qui à un moment devait
développer la vie sociale et la vie
sociale ça existait déjà avant il y
avait déjà des animaux sociaux crétacé
ça s'appelle des fourmis donc la vie
sociale si tu veux chercher qu'il a
développé en premier c'était les fourmis
et les abeilles au crétacé à l'époque du
trot dont il y avait déjà des animaux
sociaux à bordel un petit accident
écologique très bon une météorite
de la taille voilà d'une montagne quoi
c'est tout donc un petit accident
écologique près ce reptile aurait très
bien pu conduire des voitures bâtir des
gratte-ciel et inventer la télévision
oui mais là encore une fois tu prends
des ça pour des finalités
est ce que est ce qu'on est fier d'avoir
construit des voitures bâti des
gratte-ciel et inventer la télé ça c'est
la question est ce qu'on a vraiment est
ce qu'on a vraiment progressé en
construisant des voitures
sachant sa chambre que maintenant
l'écologie est devenue le principal
problème de l'humanité est ce qu'on est
vraiment allé est ce qu'on a vraiment
l'impression d'avoir progressé en ayant
accompli voiture gratte-ciel télévision
voilà je vous laisse réfléchir là dessus
c'est purement philosophique saharienne
scientifiques et nous malheureux
primates retardataires n'aurions plus de
place que dans les eaux les laboratoires
et les cirques alors citation du moins
je vois une guillemets ici donc citation
s'est mis en gras et en italique
citation de qui citation de qui de quoi
est ce que ça vient de jane russell est
ce que ça vient de ce gain est ce que ça
on ne saura pas donc voilà ça ça propose
une citation genre c'est très
intelligent ce qu'il raconte mais on ne
sait pas d'où elle vient cette citation
donc c'est difficile
voilà tout ce qui est sur internet est
vrai comme disait antoine daniel c'est
le dinosaure le plus cérébralisé de tous
sa boîte crânienne comparé la taille de
son corps est la plus grande jamais
découverte
alors on peut aller voir on peut
retourner voir jerry sonne donc jerry
sonne qui nous a fait ce joli graff la
taille du cerveau poids du corps donc
les mammifères ont donc un cerveau
comparé la taille du corps qui est plus
grand que chez les reptiles et les
dinosaures qui sont là et ici vous avez
quelques points qui correspondent donc
aux dinosaures et vous avez leur nom
juste ici pour vous y retrouver et en
gros alors ça c'est les dinosaures mais
les dinosaures non aviens mais si on
inclut les oiseaux et les dinosaures qui
ont la taille de cerveau la plus grosse
s'est définitivement les oiseaux je
rappelle que les oiseaux sont des
dinosaures donc ils comptent
biologiquement comme des dinosaures je
veux dire vous pouvez toujours dire
qu'un dinosaure ça ressemble pas un
oiseau c'est pas vrai c'est lee
dès que vous vous faites d'un dinosaure
qui ressemble pas un oiseau mais c'est
votre idée qui est fausse votre
représentation mentale de ski à un
dinosaure c'est à dire un gros lézard
certainement est complètement fausse les
dinosaures sont biologiquement plus
proche des oiseaux et les oiseaux sont
des dinosaures
point final vous pouvez toujours essayer
de discuter là dessus dans les
commentaires vous ne m'aurez pas voilà
donc le les dinosaures qui ont le plus
gros cerveau par rapport à la taille du
corps
ce sont les oiseaux et le troodon donc
il nous disait tout à l'heure qu'il
était sur le haut de la variation des
reptiles donc c'est à dire sur cette
ligne là ici donc le troodon ça doit
être un de ces points là je suppose il
n'y a pas le nom directement dessus mais
voilà ça doit être un de ces points là
donc il est à l'intérieur vous voyez du
nuage de points qui correspond aux
dinosaures non aviens qui est pas qu'ils
n'ont pas de capacités cérébrales
supérieure à celle d'un reptile
voilà c'est à dire qu'un reptile qui se
situe là est tout aussi con qu'un
troodon voilà pour dire les choses
vulgairement
c'est ça l'idée un reptile qui se trouve
là n'a rien à envier à introd dont
suivant son cerveau était plus grand que
celui d'un émeu non non bah non non je
reviens à cédric allait me il est là le
trot dont il est là la ligne aile et la
voilà il ya la séparation très claire
entre le rouge là et le vert l'a donc
non après avoir comparé la taille de son
cerveau à celle d'un mammifères modernes
les scientifiques pensent que stan honey
cause aux russes [ __ ] appelle le
troodon était aussi intelligent qu un
opossum mais oui et il pouvait encore
évoluer encore une fois de quantifier
l'intelligence à partir de la taille du
cerveau sait c'est ça vaut ce que ça
vaut
voilà une fois de plus je vous renvoie à
cette vidéo la voilà le stylo ni cause
or entre parenthèses tonique aux
horizons n'avaient pas encore compris de
quoi tu parles est c'est vrai donc
encore une fois ça doit être un report
d'un autre article
il a dû y aller chercher encore un
extrait d'un autre article pour pour ce
morceau là bref a été nommé par stenberg
en 1932 d'après un pied un fragment
demain et quelques vertèbres caudales du
crétacé supérieur de l'alberta
du coup ce qui expliquerait pourquoi
c'est devenu à nommay nubile à nomen du
biome parce que du coup il n'y avait pas
de crâne et que c'est difficile de faire
de la taxonomie sans crâne un détail à
la nomme un détail anatomique
intéressant consiste en une énorme
griffe sur le deuxième orteil
caractéristiques des déinonychosaures
nom des drôme et aux orres bordel de
merde des drôme et aux orres steinberg
classifiés à l'origine le stan honey
cause or parmi les élus rider une
famille de théropodes à l'époque de
steinberg en 1932 savez peut-être du
sens effectivement plus tard en 1951 ils
spéculent à queue puisque le stylo nique
aux orres avait un pied forte fortement
nom usuel encore une grosse traduction
bien crade et que le troodon avec un
tréma cette fois là et que le troodon
avait des dents tout aussi inhabituel il
devait être apparenté à l'époque en cas
spécimens comparable n'était disponible
pour tester la validité de l'idée un
squelette de stan honey causeur plus
complet a été découvert par die
bruxelles en 1969 squelette qui forme à
la fondation scientifique de sa célèbre
sculpture grandeur nature de sténo nique
aux ors et son descendant humanoïdes
fictifs le dinosauroïde le style unique
aux ors de 20,1 théropodes bien connu
dans les années 1980 quand les pieds et
la boîte crânienne ont été décrits en
détail l'animal est même parfois
considéré comme étant le dinosaure le
plus intelligent oui bon les dinosaures
les dinosaures
enfin je veux dire quand tu regardes un
tyrannosaure tu as 5 tonnes de muscles
et de mâchoire t'as pas besoin d'être
intelligent donc oui le troodon était
plus petit il était probablement un poil
plus malins pas aussi malin qu'un
corbeau ou qu'un perroquet encore une
fois pj curie et ça dans pizza écuries
et sa révision des troodontidés connu en
1987 à reclasser stan honey corinne et
qualys comme étant synonyme de trop aux
dons forme aux us a enfin une hauteur
enfin une information taxonomique juste
7 synonymie a largement été adoptée par
les autres paléontologiste et c'est
ainsi que tous les spécimens connu sous
le nom de stefani cause aux russes sont
maintenant désigné sous le nom de trop
dans la littérature scientifique récente
parmi les autres genres transférés dans
le genre trop on dont on retrouve
pectine oddo poli au dos taurus avec
donc normalement on may et poli au dos
taurus avec stan honey cause aux russes
tous ces noms peuvent fort bien désigner
autant de gens valides que ne formaient
qu'un seul et même animal des recherches
plus approfondies pour faire la lumière
sur la question banon il ya plus de
mystère tu viens de dire qu'il y avait
plus de mystère arrête de faire du
mystère là c'est fini c'est trop long
c'est tout voilà ils ont des caractères
crânien très développé de grandes orbite
permettant une vision diurne et nocturne
avec une vision dirigé presque à 360
degrés au vu de la position de ces
dernières c'est possible les chevaux
aussi en sont capables de plus il
dispose d'un rapport au volume crânien
sur volume total impressionnant un des
plus importants parmi les dinosaures
ce qui en fait un dinosaure capable
d'intelligence pouces et voilà on en a
déjà parlé de plus tout comme ceux qui
caractérisent les hommes d autres
hominidés l'est le stan honey causeur
possédait un organe une organisation du
cerveau différentes que l'on pourrait
justement comparé à celle de l'homme par
certains côtés alors laissez-moi
chercher une image d'un cerveau de
troodontidés juste pour qu'on voie
jusqu'à quel point ça se compare à celui
de l'homme alors dans l'article de jerry
sonne si on recherche une image du duc
de l'endocrâne de trop dont on a ça donc
ça c'est une vue de l'endocrâne c'est à
dire du moulage de la boîte crânienne de
trop dont vue du dessus alors déjà on
n'a pas grand chose à voir avec celui
d'un homme vous voyez les bulbes
olfactifs notamment qui sont hyper
développé à l'avant et ici vous avez le
les hémisphères cérébraux
ici vous avez le cervelet donc si vous
regardez accra si vous regardez un
cerveau humain par le dessus vous ne
verrez pas le cervelet parce que les
hémisphères cérébraux le recouvre
totalement et après si on va chercher
d'autres images sur internet
donc voilà par exemple cette image là
vous voyez bien ici les lobes the fact
if les hémisphères cérébraux ici le
cervelet ici avec la partie et au milieu
qui est soulevé pas grand chose à voir
avec un cerveau humain
je rappelle human brain encore une fois
on va regarder le cerveau humain juste à
titre de comparaison
voilà un cerveau humain vous voyez le
cervelet il est en dessous il n'est pas
sûr il n'est pas derrière les émissaires
et vous voyez les ailes et l'ogbl fac
tiff sont situés en dessous ils sont là
voilà donc céder tout petit lob seul
factice situé en dessous du cerveau donc
pas grand chose à voir avec celui de
trop dans par contre celui de trop dont
a beaucoup à voir avec celui des oiseaux
donc vous voyez ici par exemple donc
c'est la même image que sur jay harrison
donc avec l'albatros par exemple voyez
ici les logs olfactif qui font ça y est
à l'avant pas aussi grand que chez trop
aux dons mais ils sont là quand même
et le cervelet qui est bien exposé à
l'arrière avec les deux gros hémisphères
cérébraux sur le côté donc c'est vrai
que trop aux dons à quelques
caractéristiques partagées avec le
cerveau des oiseaux le cerveau de trop
on se compare beaucoup mieux à celui des
oiseaux qu'à celui des cas celui des
humains
ici vous avez le cerveau d'archaeopteryx
donc archéoptéryx vous voyez que c'est
pareil il ya jolie serveuse est bien
exposé à l'arrière des petits lobs
olfactif à l'avant et les hémisphères
cérébraux ici donc le cerveau trop dont
est très très similaire à celui
d'archaeopteryx et des oiseaux en
réalité pas du tout à celui des humains
mais bref voyons ce qu'il nous en dit en
outre la forme de sa caisse de résonance
et des eaux de son coup laisse à penser
que si l'évolution était s'était
poursuivi il aurait été possible de voir
émerger un proto langage c chez ces
animaux
bien qu'on soit presque sûr qu'ils aient
été capables de communiquer alors par où
je commence avec cette phrase sa caisse
de résonance de quoi de qui c'est quoi
une caisse de résonance et quel organe
appelles tu une caisse de résonance
voilà et les eaux de son coup donc
j'imagine que tu fais référence à la
glotte
enfin au pharynx en général alors je
tiens à dire que rien que sur néandertal
on a regardé les eaux du coup comme il
dit et on n'arrive pas à déterminer si
oui ou non il était capable de parler en
regardant ça voilà il y en a qui disent
oui il y en a qui disent non donc
bon il y en a plus qui disent oui quand
même et déjà avec néandertal c'est
difficile à dire en regardant juste les
eaux du coup et whatever ça veut dire la
caisse de résonance la juste avec les os
est déjà presque impossible d'arriver à
dire si néandertal était capable de
parler et néandertal ces genres l'espèce
est apte qui est la plus proche de nous
il n'ya pas plus proche de nous alors
comment tu veux sur un trot dont arrivé
à dire mais oui bien sûr il arrivait à
parler évidemment bullshit
ainsi ces dinosaures seraient devenus
l'espèce dominante si un banal accident
astronomique n'était pas survenue il ya
65 millions d'années
la chute d'un astéroïde de la taille
d'une montagne n'a rien de banal
voilà à lire l'encyclopédie du savoir
relatif et absolu de sa de bernard
werber
nous savons tous que l'encyclopédie du
savoir relatif et et absolue est une
oeuvre scientifique valide n'est ce pas
c'est une oeuvre de fiction mecque de la
fiction
ah tiens pour une fois il ya un peu de
sources ou là je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
peur ça va être quoi cette source
allant voir quels qu'est ce que tu nous
site
qu'est-ce que tu ne cites attention le
dinosaure ouyahia le dinosaure qui
aurait pu produire un être vivant de
type presque humain abadie on retrouve
les mêmes d'image bien et à lire
l'encyclopédie du savoir relatif et
absolu d'un art werber et c'est
exactement le même texte d'accord ok
donc c'est juste effectivement aripov
d'un autre report d'un d'une traduction
etc
voilà donc on attaque un nouvel article
encore copier coller la théorie du
dinosauroïde est une vraie théories
scientifiques non c'est une t71 c'est
une spéculation
c'est de la pure fiction qui a été mis
en place pour une exposition organisée
par dell russell
ça n'a rien à voir avec une théorie
scientifique c'était pour une exposition
s'était ces deux là comment on pourrait
dire c'est de la science fiction mais
avec un peu plus de science que de
fiction on va dire voilà mais rien à
voir avec une théorie scientifique non
pas du tout qui possède bien sûr comme
toute théorie ses défenseurs
ses détracteurs donc là des gens ont
créé un homme de paille 1 c'est à dire
qu'on crée une théorie scientifique
alors que ça en est pas une et on va lui
et on va construire par dessus au final
voilà on va construire par dessus une
idée qui de base est fausse
allez c'est parti surtout sur la mention
d'une convergence dont d'une adaptation
intelligente qui mènerait à ce que la
majorité des gens tendent à
l'anthropomorphisme c'est-à-dire à
posséder une tête des bras des jambes ou
une tête et quatre pattes au stade
précédent
c'est même pas français c'est même pas
français mais c'est bien de faire
mention de l'anthropomorphisme parce que
c'est dégueulasse mme anthropomorphique
cette théorie du dinosauroïde cette
théorie pourtant démontré en partie à
plusieurs et à plusieurs niveaux si on
compare l'apparence très proche des
requins et des raies par exemple alors
que ce sont deux genres totalement
différents
l'apparence très proche des requins elle
est démontrée parce que l'airé les
requins ça se ressemble
alors les réer les requins ça se
ressemble parce que ce sont des animaux
cartilagineux des poissons cartilagineux
donc c'est la même famille tu veux en
venir ou la cesse de ça veut dire quoi
cette fois il veut dire quoi ce
paragraphe bordel ça veut rien dire
ça va rien dire du tout non bref
paragraphe 1 kamoulox voilà ça comme une
loque ce paragraphe 2 à paragraphe 2
l'autre question qui me vient évidemment
à l'esprit étant donné mes connaissances
historiques est sur l'implication
prouvées du genre reptilien dans la
mythologie et histoires humaines à la
mythologie oui quand la pseudo science
se met à évoquer la mythologie j'adore
pourrait-il y avoir un rapport à ceux ci
était un as des da pourrait-il y avoir
un rapport entre ce possible
dinosauroïde qui aurait évolué
intelligemment s'il n'avait pas évoluer
intelligemment ça veut pas dire ce que
tu crois que ça veut dire
il a évolué vers l'intelligence mais il
n'a pas évolué et intelligemment le dire
ou alors c'est de l'intelligent design
ne s'est pas tarie merde
s'il n'avait toujours mystérieusement
car même l' impact météoritique et le
volcanisme attesté n'explique pas la
totale disparition de ces petits
dinosaures par exemple alors que leur
petit leur petit pois les mammifères
survivaient tout aussi mystérieusement
eux les dinosaures n'ont pas tous
disparu les oiseaux sont toujours parmi
nous à il n'aurait finalement pas
disparu le dinosaure et se serait
rapidement adapté est muté en oiseau de
différentes tailles thèse officielle a
put 1 et c'est parti
et quand on lit quand tu lis à la thèse
officielle
tu sais que tu rentres tu as en train de
franchir le rubicon la veillée déposés
ici tous tout bon sens et c'est parti
pour les théories du complot est là et
bien quand on vous sort thèse officielle
vous savez déjà qu'on va vous opposer
une thèse officielle a enfin les
méchants tenants de la thèse officielle
aux gentils chercheurs de vérité
c'est désespérant de dire ça c'est
désespérant j'en suis même pas 1 1 car
ça fait déjà une heure mais et si les
plus intelligents d'entre eux ne
s'étaient pas transformer en oiseau
justement essayer avait finalement créer
les bases d'une première civilisation
peut-être souterraine vu l'environnement
de l'époque avec les capacités
d'adaptation des reptiles facilité
taille vous fermer leur gueule les à dix
doigts ou quoi adela et s'il avait
finalement créer les bases d'une
première civilisation peut-être
souterraine vu l'environnement de
l'époque avec les capacités d'adaptation
des reptiles facilité c'était pas des
reptiles les dinosaures sont pas des
reptiles ce sont des archosaures plus
proche des oiseaux que d autres reptiles
donc non des capacités de reptiles mes
fesses un ne sait rien tu ne comprend
rien et l'environnement de l'époque tu
ferais bien de le d2 le sait quoi
l'environnement de l'époque d'ailleurs
c'est quoi l'on vient de rendre le trot
dont il a vécu pendant plusieurs
millions d'années c'est quoi
l'environnement de l'époque il a vécu de
l'alaska au sud des états unis pendant
plusieurs millions d'années c'est quoi
l'environnement de l'époque
vas-y je t'attends qui a fini par
rejoindre la mémoire des premiers
humains
je pourrais même ajouter directement ici
que la théorie des hanouna qui ayant
créé la race humaine pour l'utiliser
pourrait y avoir en fait cette origine
bien terrestres
donc voilà les dinosaures les dinosaures
ont évolué en reptilien qui ont créé la
race humaine et qui maintenant les
reptiliens ils vivent sous terre mais
oui mais oui tout à fait alors juste un
truc si un animal de ville sous terre il
serait pas comme ça un animal qui vit
sous terre ces petits trapus ça a des
gros bras pour creuser et ça a pas des
grands yeux au contraire
oh [ __ ] ça un animal qui vit sous
terre regardez une taupe doré je vais
vous montrer une taupe doré ça c'est un
animal qui vit sous terre un animal qui
vit sous terre c'est à ça que ça
ressemble ça ressemble à une taupe c'est
un pas dieu ou des tout petits yeux saad
énorme bras trapu pour creuser vous
pouvez regarder tonné maintien le rat
taupe ne rate aucune voilà on en a
atteint ce point là on a atteint le
point dur à trop soutenu ben voilà le
râteau cnu vous voyez ça a une sale
gueule mais ça surtout un tout petit
oeil voilà pas de pas d'oreilles bref ça
n'a pas de queue non plus bon ça la
rigueur c'est le cas aussi de ce truc là
donc pourquoi pas d'ailleurs vous
noterez au passage que pour rendre cette
chose plausible cette prise de vue est
fait de telle sorte qu'on ne voit pas là
que la très très longue queue du trot
dont le troodon avait pris une queue qui
était presque aussi longue que le reste
du corps
1 donc il ya aussi un petit peu de
larnaca dans tout ça
bref donc voilà ça c'est un animal qui
vit sous terre ça c'est un animal qui
vit en plein jour voilà d'autant qu'on
sait maintenant enfin d'autant que la
théorie qui prévaut en ce moment c'est
que la bipédie humaine est en fait une
adaptation
au soleil c'est à dire que le fait de se
tenir debout au lieu d'avoir
au lieu de se tenir à quatre pattes
permet d'éviter que le dos soit
entièrement exposé au soleil et donc de
déjà ça évite toutes les mutations dues
à leur dû aux uv et puis ça évite
surtout de perdre de perdre de l'eau à
longueur de temps parce que ont su voilà
donc ça évite de perdre notre
transpiration donc voilà annoncé
bullshit tout ça c'est du bullshit
un animal qui vit sous terre ça
ressemble pas à ça pas du tout ça à des
tout petits yeux des là pour commencer
ça a des gros bras et ça et puis ça
marcherait pas debout pourquoi tu veux
marcher debout c'est la pire postures
possibles marchaient debout quand tu vis
sous terre je veux dire qu'est ce que ça
a aucun sens ça n'a aucun sens s'il est
si les sites et reptiles ya là ils ont
évolué depuis 65 millions d'années sous
terre à l'abri après avoir créé les
humains genre je suis désolé mais en 60
millions d'années ils ont pas pu garder
cette gueule là voilà c'est pas possible
donc suivant alors de satan voilà on a
alors on a eu le bullshit
donc on a eu en trois ans en trois
lignes on a eu théorie du complot
les hanouna qui a donc les reptiliens
et maintenant référence biblique de
satan le serpent jusqu'au symbole
médical le caducée notre symbolique est
rempli de lien avec la race reptilienne
la reptilien ne sont pas une race tout
au plus c'est un fils hommes voilà nous
avons même dans notre propre cerveau une
partie des nommés reptilienne faux faux
faux faux faux faux faux faux ses
fossettes cette théorie du cerveau
reptilien a été réfutée des millions de
fois ça s'appelle la théorie voilà ça
s'appelle la théorie du cerveau tri
unique voilà
et cette théorie du cerveau trioux
nickel a été des milliers de fois des
bunkers voilà il ya critique du concept
je vous renvoie vers tout ce paragraphe
voilà mais en gros si vous voulez
critique rapide du cerveau trilles
unique le problème c'est que en gros
diviser le cerveau humain en une partie
qui serait reptilienne c'est-à-dire
primitive et une partie qui serait
mammalienne c'est-à-dire dérivés ça ça
veut rien dire du tout tout simplement
parce que la partie reptilienne elle est
commune à tout le monde donc finalement
c'est pas un cerveau reptilien c'est un
cerveau qui est commun à tout le monde
c'est une partie du cerveau qui est
commun aux reptiles qui est commun aux
oiseaux qui est commun aux humains qui
est commun à tous les mammifères dont
qu'elle ait pas plus reptilienne
qu'autre chose cette partie du cerveau
c'est juste qu'elle est en commun aussi
avec les reptiles et après le néocortex
et fit effectivement n'est pas en commun
avec celui des reptiles par contre les
reptiles ont un équivalent du néocortex
qui a donné le néocortex des oiseaux qui
est très différent du néocortex des
rêves des mammifères
donc c'est déjà la première critique du
qu'on peut faire au concept du cerveau
tri unique du cerveau reptilien sait que
la partie qu'on appelle cerveau
reptilien n'a rien de particulier aux
reptiles
elle est chez tout le monde elle est
chez tous les animaux y compris les
mammifères donc suivant la partie
reptilienne passeur la couche la plus
ancienne du cerveau humain
en fait comme on sait maintenant que les
oiseaux descendent très probablement des
dinosaures reptilien les dinosaures tout
court par reptilien c'est bien la grande
majorité de la symbolique humaine avec
ses aigles et autres faucons qui se
rapporte bien au genre reptilien
d'origine maintenant le genre la race le
genre voilà on fait ce qu'on veut avec
la taxonomie on s'en bat les couilles
deux moments que ça sert notre propos on
fait ce qu'on veut avec la taxonomie on
s'en fout allons plus loin car si
certains dinosaures auraient évolué en
tout en autre chose que des oiseaux ce
qui est parfaitement possible
scientifiquement il ya des divergences
et des nouveaux bourgeons oui en or et
ont trouvé en or et ont retrouvé la
trace sans vraiment l'identifier et oui
il existe encore de nombreux fossiles
non identifié pour une fois je suis
d'accord il existe effectivement de
nombreux fossiles qu'on n'a pas encore
trouvé un
les gens qui nous pose la question
souvent de est ce qu'on a est-ce qu'on
n'aurait pas déjà tout trouvé la réponse
est non on a peut-être trouvé un pour
cent de ski à trouver quoi mais là le
grand truc c'est là est ce que en gros
une race intelligente aurait pu exister
il ya 60 millions d'années sans qu'on
s'en rende compte
bah encore une fois une existence
antiseptique pourrait expliquer ou s'il
avait une existence absolument
antiseptique qui ne laissent aucune
trace
c'est possible autrement on l'aurait vu
dinosauroïde où l'évolution des
dinosaures dinosauroïde est le terme
scientifique utilisé pour désigner
l'objet d'une hypothèse proposé par
plusieurs scientifiques basés sur une
évolution des dinosaures troodontidés
qui ne se seraient pas éteint cette
hypothèse correspond à l'adaptation
progressive des dinosaures à une forme
anthropomorphique une forme reptilien
une forme de reptilien alors encore une
fois et je le répète le dinosauroïde on
va chercher directement sur wikipédia
comme ça on va avoir directement le
dinosauroïde voilà les reptiles
humanoïdes
alors évidemment vous devez mythologie
science ufologie théorie du complot bon
on va chercher directement la partie qui
parle de delerue seul voilà donc voilà
le dinosauroïde c'est une expérience de
pensée
voilà ça c'est le mot depuis tout à
l'heure j'essaie de formuler ça comme il
faut voilà là c'est bon le dinosauroïde
c'est une expérience de penser que dell
russell a mis au point en 1981 deux
basés sur sa découverte du premier crâne
de sténo nique aux orres qui est donc en
fait un trou au don et qui est donc il a
fait ça juste pour une exposition c'est
purement une expérience de pensée ce
n'est pas une hypothèse scientifique
valides ou quoi que ce une théorie ou
quoi que ce soit c'est une expérience de
pensée voilà de la spéculation à l'état
brut
on est d'accord y'a rien de sérieux
derrière ça bref à l'adaptation
progressive de dinosaures à une forme
anthropomorphique voilà donc
l'adaptation confondre évolution avec
une adaptation
placer l'homme au sommet de l'évolution
bref comme d'habitude un des erreurs
banal classique nul
en 1982 les scientifiques des bruxelles
et r seguin ont publié un article
détaillant la reconstitution complète de
sténo nico zaurus une espèce désormais
assignés au genre trop haut dans basé
sur le squelette découverte en alberta
en 1967 avec l'étude du trot dont les
chercheurs ont entrepris la tâche
d'imaginer une évolution possible de
l'animal si elle est si elle n'était pas
éteinte un animal maintenance et féminin
l'idée de base avait avait une entrée
très intéressante à savoir que le
dinosaure trop ou dont l un des plus
intelligents de son temps qu'il avait un
gros cerveau par rapport à la taille du
corps comme ces petits dinosaures dont
j'ai déjà parlé de tout ça donc géorgie
revient pas et le cerveau était pas si
gros que ça comme ces petits dinosaures
étaient légers et actif chasseurs de
proies comme les lézards et les petits
mammifères primitif avec une vue
stéréoscopique capable d'attaquer
même avec une faible 1 faible nombre
d'heures de lumière les caractéristiques
du dinosauroïde ont été posés en prenant
de trop aux dons et son évolution à long
terme jeu
pareil je louais le français ainsi le
dinosauroïde serait à dinosaures à la
capacité d'une grande intellectuelle la
capacité d'un grand intellectuel qui lui
permettrait de compenser sa faible
vitesse sa faible vitesse non mais t'as
vu les jambes du machin sa faible
vitesse vaches il t'a vu les jambes du
truc aller je rappelle l'éléctro dont ce
sont des animaux qui sont dits jti
gradins donc c'est des animaux qui
courent sur le bout des doigts
c'est des animaux qui courent sur les
doigts contrairement à nous qui courront
sur les talons ils courent sur les
doigts ça les rend beaucoup plus rapide
1 ils sont vachement rapide donc je vois
pas de quoi tu parles avec de simples
outils de décision et de développement
et qui lui permettrait des tactiques de
fuite ou de poursuite de leurs
prédateurs et leur proie d'une manière
plus efficace les gagnants ceci n'est
qu'une hypothèse mais sommes nous sûrs
qu'un dinosaure de type dinosauroïde
n'ait jamais existé intel squelette
pourrait attendre quelque part une
hypothèse absurde point d'interrogation
alors se pourrait-il s'agir d'une
hypothèse absurde donc une fois de plus
il ya un lien qui nous renvoie vers
l'origine de ce texte tellement mal
écrit je suppose donc paranormal
réseauter mist forumactif voilà ça veut
dire ce que ça veut dire
est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on pourrait être
passé à côté d'un crâne de dinosauroïde
bat déjà regardons russell dinosauroïde
skull à quoi ça ressemblerait un crâne
de dinosauroïde ça ressemblerait à ça
d'après die bruxelles c'est le crâne qui
a été créée par die bruxelles a donc
imaginé par un paléontologue alors on
peut voir que il est différent d'un
petit trot dont je vous ai trouvé le
troodon la part la taille du museau donc
le museau et court je rappelle que c'est
un crâne qui est fortement inspiré du
crâne humain donc fatalement le museau
et cours fatalement il ya un gros
cerveau alors ce gros cerveau il se fait
au prix de la perte de certaines fausses
du crâne donc je rappelle que c'est un
archosaures donc les archosaures ont une
orbite une fausse en théorie terre ici
vous avez les narines et ici vous avez
la fosse post orbitaire et l' hymne
enfin la fosse la fosse temporal
inférieure est ici vous devriez avoir
une fausse temporal supérieur donc voilà
orbite en faux santé orbitaire narines
fausse temporal inférieur et regardez le
sur le sommet du crâne ya la fosse
temporal supérieur le problème de cette
fausse temporal supérieur c'est que pour
la voir c'est que pour avoir un gros
cerveau faut la virer alors c'est pas un
problème en soi puisque les pigeons si
vous regardez ici là je vous ai aussi
chercher un crâne de pigeons déjà donc
les oiseaux en général ont perdu ces
fausses temporal supérieur ils leurs
ancêtres les dinosaures les avaient ils
les ont perdus donc c'est pas
complètement impossible de les perdre
mais déjà voilà appelé ce truc-là intro
dont ce serait effectivement déjà abusé
bons mets donc il n'est pas complètement
impossible qu une anatomie pareil ait pu
exister après est ce qu'on aurait pu
passer à côté ba ma foi je reviens à
l'argument qui dirait que ce serait une
espèce dominante si ce truc là est
apparu et a dominé le monde par le passé
ça veut dire qu'il y en avait partout or
on en a trouvé nulle part donc un truc
qu'on est censé trouver partout et qu'on
trouve nulle part
ça commence à faire beaucoup sachant que
à côté de ça on a trouvé des choses
qui n'étaient pas présentes partout par
exemple tyrannosaurus rex
on y en avait pas partout il y en avait
quand d'amérique du nord et on en a
trouvé plein voilà donc et toutes les
espèces fossiles qu'on connaît on en a
on en a trouvé beaucoup ou très peu ou
un tout petit peu ou quasiment rien mais
on les a trouvés
et pourtant elle n'était pas forcément
présente partout donc maintenant là on
parle d'un dinosauroïde qui aurait
dominé le monde et dont on n'aurait
jamais rien trouvé
voilà donc accepter que cette chose là
est exister et qu'on l'ait pas trouvé je
veux bien mais à la condition que cette
chose-là n'ai jamais été très digne très
répandue sur le globe
voilà si ce truc là n'avaient n'a vécu
que dans une petite région du monde et
que cette petite région du monde n'est
pas exploré ou qu'il n'y a pas de par
exemple qu'il n'y a pas de
d'affleurements du bon âge pour le
trouver
à la limite on pourrait le croire par
contre si cette chose-là à dominer le
monde
60 millions d'années avant l'apparition
de l'homme et après la disparition des
dinosaures non aviens là c'est mort
c'est mort je veux dire ça n'existe pas
non la preuve d'absence n'est certes pas
l'absence de preuves mais il ya au bout
d'un moment où on peut pas construire
n'importe quoi sur l'argument de la
preuve d'absence n'est pas l'absence de
preuves
voilà c'est pas parce qu'on n'en a pas
trouvé que ça n'existe pas je suis
d'accord mais alors c'est pas parce
qu'on en a pas trouvé qu'on peut
inventer que ça à dominer le monde
voilà non c'est non on continue
ceci n'est qu'une hypothèse non j'ai
déjà lu ça même du côté des dinosaures
ont ils vraiment tous disparu à la même
époque
à la même époque non les oiseaux existe
encore certains n'y aurait-il pas
survécu jusqu'à ce que l'homme s'en
souviennent finalement dans ces légendes
et histoires
cela semble être le cas si on se réfère
au nombre de traces de plus en plus
nombreuses de part le monde
les traces de plus en plus nombreuses de
parlement
et nous renvoie vers une source donc on
va pas s'en priver
les dinosaures impossible eh ben les
dinosaures impossible je sens que j'ai
trouvé le prochain des bonnes kg
pénitence
wouah
les dinosaures d'impossible bah oui
c'est des dinosaures impossible alors ce
vase l'a étudiée par adrienne mayor ceci
est un crâne ceci n'est pas un spécimen
vivant voilà donc c'est ceci n'a pas été
négligée ceci a bien été étudiés par
adrienne mayor qui identifie aussi comme
étant un crâne donc oui les gens de la
grèce antique ont peut-être découvert
des fossiles des crânes qu'ils ont pris
pour des monstres mais c'est un crâne ça
c'est pas un animal vivant ça c'est des
faux on sait depuis longtemps les pierre
dick a on le sait depuis très longtemps
que ses défauts et il ya une il ya une
raison toute simple pour laquelle on
voit tout de suite que ses défauts les
pierre dick à viennent d'amérique du sud
ceci est un tricératops il n'y a jamais
eu de tricératops en amérique du sud
jamais donc fin de l'histoire alors on a
découvert en france des silex taillés
d'une civilisation âgés de 20 millions
d'années sur lesquels sont gravés des
dinosaures les burdy gallien ah oui je
vais vous montrer les burdy gallien un
exemple de pareilles dolly mais alors
comme on n'en fait plus donc voilà les
burdy gallien voici les pierres qu'ils
auraient taille et donc on va admettre
que les exemples qui sont mis sur
internet sont les exemples les plus
probants 1
on est d'accord voilà le mec dans le
bouquin nous montre ça on est censé voir
ça un magnifique pari d'owlient mesdames
et messieurs et c'est que ça a laissé la
civilisation soi-disant burdy aliens là
c'est que ça c'est des trucs
voilà voici ce que voici le caillou
voici ce que on est censé voir cesser de
l'appareil de liés à l'état brut 1
le dire là j'ai pas meilleur exemple de
pari d'owlient que ça la grotte de
bernifal où on est on voit des gravures
et donc il ya un truc qui ressemble à
rien alors on va dire que c'est un
reptilien voilà il ya çà çà çà ressemble
à rien donc on va dire que c'est un
reptilien les figurines dakar mme barrau
découvert en 1944 bas les gens ont plus
le droit de rien imaginé donc les tribus
riz les tribus aborigènes de queensland
australie raconte l'histoire de yahoo
yards un animal au long cou muninn
nageoires cela ressemble étonnamment à
un plésiosaure oui mais cette histoire a
été racontée dans les années 70 dans les
années 90 donc c'est les tribus
aborigènes
certes mais qui ont dit ça dans les
années 90 donc elles ne sont pas exempts
de culture et d'avoir éventuellement vue
et intégrée du coude et des éléments
qui ne sont pas de leur culture à la
base ah ouais mais là en fait il ya une
cascade de trucs on va arrêter de faire
cascades et ses sources parce que ça va
pas aller au zimbabwe il ya des
peintures rupestres qui ressemble à des
brontosaures bah ouais ça ressemble
aussi à des crocodiles
voilà il y a ce petit truc qui a été
découvert dans le ghana c'est un petit
poids à peser l'or et qui ressemble
étrangement à un animal à quatre pattes
avec une grosse tête
alors je veux bien mais si vous voulez
je veux bien qu'on me dise ah ça
ressemble vachement un brontosaure mais
est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on va vraiment me
faire croire
est-ce qu'on va vraiment vouloir me
faire croire que les brontosaures avait
une grosse tête comme ça la réponse est
non
les brontosaures il avait une toute
petite tête enfin les brontosaures
juillet pour voir les sauropodes
de manière générale donc on va me dire
non ça ressemble à sauropodes
oui mais avec une énorme tête ah oui
mais on a bien le droit à une petite
licence artistique a donc on a le droit
à une petite licence artistique pour la
tête mais pas sur tout le reste du corps
donc en gros moi j'ai pas le droit de
dire que tout ça c'est une licence
artistique et que c'est complètement
inventé mais par contre eux ils ont le
droit de dire que c'est que la tête
c'est une licence artistique va te faire
[ __ ]
va te faire [ __ ] c'est une chose qui a
été inventée est une chose qui a été
inventé je veux dire c'est pas parce que
je dessine un truc que c'est forcément
vrai voilà donc voilà il ya des animaux
qui ressemblent à des poules
eux ils voient des add rose or voilà
donc ça c'est une poule ça c'est un à
droz or c'est la même chose la même
chose voilà l'amérique du nord les
pétroglyphes anciens donc là évidemment
il nous montre les grands classiques
alors cela je les connais pas par contre
je connais celui qui a été débloquée par
le quellec donc j'ai fini par retrouver
l'image c'est sur notre page facebook
stop science donc on en a parlé donc
voici ici le dessin du ptérosaures donc
un dessin réalisé par les amérindiens
il ya mille ans en gros et voici donc ce
que contient réellement ce dessin donc
vous voyez qu'en gros là la trace
blanche qui fait le tour le contour du
ppte et rose or en fait ça contient une
espèce de motifs très très difficile à
interpréter j'ai envie de dire un petit
bonhomme qui fait la tête du ppte et
rose or et ce truc là qui fait elle donc
un autre bonhomme qui fait l'ale l'autre
aile du thé rose or et évidemment les
pieds aussi
donc voilà c'était juste une illusion
d'optique eux j'aurais aucun mal à
admettre que tout ça aussi c'était aussi
des illusions d'optique
voilà c'est tout c'est des gens qui ont
repassé quand on veut voir ce qu'on veut
on voit ce qu'on veut voilà ça c'est
pareil quand on veut voir un dinosaure
en voit un dinosaure moi si j'ai envie
de voir une girafe j'y vois une girafe
là c'est un animal là ça peut être un
animal quelconque je lis ça peut être
n'importe quoi voilà encore encore un
animal avec un long coup ça ne peut être
qu'un dinosaure les girafes ça n'existe
pas 1
surtout pas en egypte d'ailleurs là non
il habitait beaucoup trop loin de
l'afrique les égyptiens pour connaître
pour connaître les les girafes pareil il
connaissait pas les crocodiles je veux
dire ça c'est un crocodile les mecs ça
c'est un oiseau
voilà ce gros truc là bah ouais c'est un
monstre mythologique pas vraiment n'a
pas vraiment de quoi fouetter un chat
et puis bon on continue je veux dire il
ya des tas de trouver une mosaïque voilà
notre ça c'est des épées avec des
lézards dessus tout de suite c'est
forcément un dinosaure ça aussi c'est
forcément un dinosaure
les dragons c'est tous des dinosaures je
rappelle qu'on a fait une vidéo aussi un
surtout ça les dragons et les dinosaures
up dragon et dinosaures voilà on a fait
toute une vidéo là dessus où on parle
justement du rapport entre dragons et
dinosaures et pour finir que sur le fait
qu'il ya aucun rapport entre dragons et
dinosaures quand on regarde avec minutie
les
quand on regarde avec minutie le dossier
on se rend compte qu'il a aucun rapport
entre dragons et dinosaures on va aussi
nous montrer encore vagues je suppose
à nant pire que ça on nous montre une
espèce de de merde qui a été repêché et
qui serait un plésiosaure alors qu'en
fait ça a été démontré que c'est un
requin alors je sais bien qu évidemment
là comme ça ça ressemble par qu'un parce
que la chair est complètement décomposer
mais en gros il faut vous imaginer que
ça c'est la boîte crânienne du requin
donc avec le cerveau qui serait situé là
dedans là vous avez les les globes pour
les yeux là vous avez du coup les
vertèbres les nageoires du requin et
puis bah là le reste du corps
c'est tout c'est ça ressemble à un
plésiosaure parce que toute la chair
autour de la colonne vertébrale et de la
boîte crânienne s'est décomposé mais
voilà c'est juste un requin c'est tout
ça a été démontrée voilà le fameux
dinosaures dans korvac c'est forcément à
stégosaure mais encore une fois on met
des licences artistique
là où on veut mes bons amis on on met
des licences artistique là où on veut
donc si vous admettez que c'est un style
aux orres il va falloir m'expliquer
pourquoi ce stégosaure a des cornes ou
des grandes oreilles parce que les
stégosaures n'avait ni l'un ni l'autre
donc il faut admettre une licence
artistique au niveau de cette corne
oui mais bon si aux conventions semé
admettre des licences artistique bah moi
je vous dis que cette corne en fait elle
est bien réelle que cet animal
là c'est un set un buffle ou quelque
chose du genre
et puis en fait ces trucs là ce sont les
pétales d'une fleur de lotus en
arrière-plan fleur de lotus que
d'ailleurs on détecte que d'ailleurs on
voit sur les le reste de la mosaïque
donc cela la la la la
voilà tous et toutes ses mosaïques là
elles ont aussi des animaux en avec en
fond des fleurs de lotus
hélas celui là comme par hasard ce
serait pas une fleur de lotus non non ce
serait les vraies plaques d'un
stégosaure donc non voilà plus du tout
donc s'il faut admettre une licence
artistique pour que pour que ça colle à
votre théorie bullshit bas je vois pas
pourquoi moi je me bats je me priverais
de faire une licence artistique sans
votre sur ma théorie bullshit à moi
voilà un petit des dragons de komodo
décès la campagne ils ont survécu depuis
le mésozoïque va te faire [ __ ] va me
trouver un fossile de dragon de komodo
du cénozoïque du mésozoïque vas-y
cherche
cherche va chercher un fossile de
coelacanthe baisser la cote actuelle son
genre c'est la team herria je te mets au
défi de me trouver un fossile de lahti
mejia t fossile vivant tu te les fous au
cul voilà ça c'est des conneries ça y
est là on atteint le point on atteint le
point où je m'énerve et ça tombe bien
parce qu'on atteint aussi le point on va
commencer à parler des crânes des formes
et 1
elle est pas belle la vie bon c'est une
très belle idée un peu dépassé
l'anthropomorphisme jeu même jeu mais la
ponctuation ou je veux il n'y en a pas
plus limité et éventuellement aux
mammifères et l'intelligence du poulpe
par exemple démontre le peu de alors
l'intelligence du poulpe par exemple
démontre déjà ça c'est faux un exemple
ne démontre rien fin de l'histoire
the dial la phrase est fausse déjà à ce
niveau là l'intelligence du peuple du
poulpe par exemple démontre c'est un non
sens voilà un exemple ne démontre rien
démontre le peu de cas dont on fait la
nature des théories humaines de
l'évolution ah oui donc maintenant ça ne
remettait pas en question la théorie de
darwin dans le premier paragraphe mais
maintenant ça l'armé en question bah oui
maintenant anti évolutionnisme on
rajoute à la liste
il n'empêche que d'affirmer que tous les
dinosaures survivants se sont
obligatoirement transformer en azote
heigl ta gueule
ta gueule au tous les dinosaures
survivants se sont transformés en oiseau
mais t'as rien compris les oiseaux
existait déjà archéoptéryx le premier
oiseau 150 millions d'années c'est bien
avant 65 millions d'années
les oiseaux ont survécu à la limite
crétacé tertiaire ils sont les
dinosaures se sont pas transformés en
oiseau météo a rien pigé tu vois voilà
c'est ça c'est pour ça que c'est chiant
c'est des gens qui jouent à rien et est
du coup ils pillent qui construisent des
monuments des théories monumentale sur
une base d'ignorance je dirai comment
voulez-vous que moi j'arrive derrière et
que je conserve mon calme
franchement bref donc les dinosaures
survivants se sont obligatoirement
transformer en oiseau n'est pas très
scientifique non plus bas non non je
suis d'accord c'est pas scientifique de
dire ça je suis d'accord
les dinosaures survivants se sont
transformés en oiseau c'est de la merde
ça je suis d'accord avec toi
c'est pourtant ce qui est retenu
officiellement aujourd'hui tu as oublié
de rajouter c'est pourtant ce fils qui
est retenu par ma petite gueule parce
que j'ai envie de bâtir mal théorie sur
ça parce que c'est ce qui m'arrange
oui c'est ça qui t'arrange en fait
réflexion faite il se dinosauroïde a
existé et existent toujours cachés selon
certains chercher sur internet et vous
verrez vous verrez des dinosauroïde ils
existent et ils sont cachés sur internet
et qu'il a récupéré finalement à ce que
l'être
en plus là ces gens recherchés vous-même
quoi c'est là l'argument du va chercher
toi même et qu'il a récupéré finalement
est ce qu'elle est relativement proche
de l'être humain
on sait pas comment puisque de basile à
un squelette d'arc au sort alors un
squelette de l'être humain à partir d'un
archosaures une fois de plus ta mère oui
la fabrique et l'être humain toujours
selon certaines théories où il a
fabriqué l'être humain selon certaines
théories c'est cela oui bah c'est à dire
oui mais encore une fois
faut il à il a fait des essais du coup
avec les australopithèques ça c'est les
brouillons en fait les australopithèques
ou bien sahel entre opus toumaï enfin
homo erectus cdc quoi c'est des
tentatives avortées
c'est qu'on est censé comprendre quoi
l'at on trouvait finalement est assimilé
à un ancêtre de l'être humain
certainement pas on aurait fait la
différence quand même vous avez vu la
gueule liquide a enfin jeu
je sais pas si j'ai gardé la photo mais
s'il donc vous voyez la tronche qu'il a
ça quand même rien à voir avec un être
humain déjà il n'a pas de dents donc il
n'a pas de dents il a une fausse en
théorie terre il faut ce post orbitaire
qui a pas sur un crâne humain alors non
on leur a certainement pas assimiler un
être humain non donc basta j'ai envie de
dire ça déjà ta question on a la réponse
c'est bon ou fait-il partie des fossiles
mal identifiés ou même rejeté par la
science officielle a alors mal identifié
à la limite j'étais sur le point de dire
que quand même une gueule comme ça ça se
reconnaît donc mal identifié faudrait
voir à pas déconner faut vraiment
prendre les gens pour des imbéciles mais
évidemment malhonnêteté intellectuelle
oblige rejetée par la science officielle
parce qu'il y à une science officielle
je vous le rappelle il y à une science
officielle parce qu'on est comme une
secte
on est comme une secte et le canton
passe une thèse en fait c'est un rite
initiatique et où on est sacré
francs-maçons par des illuminati
reptilien qui veulent pas qu'on parle
d'eux mais qui viennent quand même à la
cérémonie
donc ils sont obligés de prendre le bus
pour venir et du coup il se cache avec
des chapeaux mais on reconnaît pas les
chapeaux parce que c'est des chapeaux
fait en latex et le latex c'est
diabolique
je sais pas c'est ma théorie bullshit à
moi j'ai envie de l'exposé alors je les
expose quoi évolution vous avez dit
évolution oui crâne peu ordinaire
cherchant trop pologne non conformiste
alors tu aurais dû marquer crétins
cherche a pas trouvé la réponse à ces
questions parce que ces crânes là tous
ekranas ont été étudiés tous les crânes
des formes et n'ont aucun mystère pour
les gens qui veulent bien s'arrêter deux
secondes sur les publications
je veux dire c'est on sait très bien
comment on fabrique des crânes ovale
comme ça
mais pour ça encore une fois il suffit
il faudrait s'intéresser à la bonne
littérature scientifique et donc des
anthropologues peu conformiste et my
hand a il y en a ils ont déjà étudié
tout ça mais bon évidemment quand on
choisit de les ignorer et de laisser des
questions déjà répondu en suspens 1
quand on préfère s'asseoir sur un le
mystère reste entier plutôt que de voir
que la réponse est à portée de main va
évidemment bien évidemment on écrit des
merdes comme ça voilà les théories
officielles de l'évolution de l'homme
sont remises en cause par de nombreuses
découvertes
ces nouveaux éléments m ta terre tout
édifice des théories paléontologique va
chier va chier va chier va chier ça rien
ça ne remet rien en cause
ça ne remet rien en cause je viens de
t'expliquer qu'il y avait toute une
littérature associés là on peut même
aller la chercher si tu veux sur coca
cola google scholar j'ai écrit google
colère google scholar voilà donc crâne
déformé et on peut même écrire burgondes
parce que je sais que les burgondes le
faisait voilà donc les craintes des
formes et voilà même les burgondes le
faisais des formes et le crâne à faire
des crânes ovoïde comme ça alors est ce
qu'on va trouver va évidemment il ya des
pages qui sont sautés alors c'est un peu
le problème aussi c'est que vous voyez
il ya des gens qui étudient les crânes
des formes et déjà déjà de base on peut
et voilà comment le crâne déformé été
fait voyez ça m'a fait ça m'a
littéralement pris 20 secondes pour
trouver de la littérature scientifique
sur les crânes déformés et comment ils
étaient fabriqués
enfin et comment on générait des crânes
déformés donc voilà un enfant cerveau
plein bois de crânienne plastique on
applique des bandages et en défendent le
crâne fin de l'histoire
vingt secondes pour trouver un article
scientifique alors son appel à
l'ignorance à la con là voilà où on peut
seul maître donc non mes théories
paléontologique elles tiennent fort de
boue
et elle t'emmerde l'image d'épinal
donner au public concernant la
préhistoire consiste à dire que l'homme
descend du singe
c'est une image d'epinal en effet
puisque encore une fois c'est faux
l'homme à un ancêtre commun avec le
chimpanzé
c'est la phrase correcte pourtant quand
on se penche un peu plus près sur la
préhistoire les choses ne sont pas aussi
simples
bah oui puisque l'homme descend du singe
est faux il est admis par exemple que
l'homme de néanderthal et l'homme de cro
magnon deux races intelligente [ __ ]
les eaux plus parlera ce bordel de merde
est génétiquement différentes vécu à la
même époque
entre 30 et 70 mille ans oui et donc le
néanderthal cet état alors que le cro
magnon a continué sa route et a donné
par évolution l'homme moderne l'homme de
cro magnon était déjà un homme moderne
mais bref que nous connaissons cette
approche de la préhistoire et plus riche
et plus pertinente que l'idée
d'évolution uniforme s'il y a eu à
certaines époques de razz intelligente
sur la planète pourquoi ne pas imaginer
trois quatre cinq races terrestre
intelligente à une même époque
ouais bah je veux dire les dauphins
aussi sont intelligents les perroquets
aussi donc oui on peut imaginer
plusieurs espèces intelligentes par as
étrange découverte il ya beaucoup de
découvertes de crâne très troublant dans
le bassin du zambèze suis retrouvé un
crâne moderne fossilisés qui aurait
vraisemblablement plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'années
rien de surprenant il s'agirait d'un
crâne plus moderne que le néanderthal
mais antérieure au néandertal un fait
qui bouscule toutes les chronologie
établie non non le crâne du zambèze à
laquelle vous faites auquel vous faites
référence c'est ça figure 2 basse et
homo heidelbergensis donc voilà le crâne
du zambèze auquel vous faites référence
etc de crâne d'un homo heidelbergensis
et il est très bien intégré d'albert
gagnent 6 ancêtre commun de homo sapiens
et de l'homme de néandertal
il est antérieure sapiens et néandertal
je vois pas le problème
dans les années tranche 30 pardon
proches dans les années 30 proche de
chihuahua au mexique fut découverte une
grande dans une grotte un crâne
étrange le volume de ce crâne et 1400
centimètres cube pour un petit squelette
il fut surnommé starchild littéralement
l'enfant des étoiles
ce crâne
symétrie parfaite et un volume
harmonieux ce qui exclut d'emblée l'idée
de malformation est issu d'une
pathologie crânienne la structure
osseuse s'est avéré être deux fois plus
résistante et deux fois plus légère
qu'un crâne d'homo sapiens il ressemble
à quoi cela star sean ça m'était débit
alors ça ça c'est ce à quoi un crâne
ressemblent quand on n'y coupe la partie
antérieure
c'est à dire c'est ça c'est ce à quoi un
crâne ressemblent si vous enlevez ce
morceau là en fait donc saharienne
mystérieux il fait 1400 centimètres
cubes parce que ses volumes moyens d'un
crâne humain
enfin de la cavité endocrânienne d'un
et puis bah il a été trouvé sur un petit
squelette parce que les enfants aussi
ont le droit d'avoir des gros cerveau
d'ailleurs les enfants ont
proportionnellement des plus gros
cerveau par rapport à leur corps que les
adultes donc aucun problème encore une
fois non la raison pour laquelle ce truc
a l'air bizarre c'est juste parce que
c'est cette partie là qu'ils retiraient
ça c'est la tronche qu'à un crâne humain
quand vous enlevez la mâchoire en fait
parce que vous êtes vous atterrissez
directement dans la cavité crânienne et
il n'y a pas le palais ici me voyais la
limite du palais qui a été péter et ça
c'est des sas et les nerfs optiques qui
passent par là donc n'y a pas deux voilà
y'a pas de soucis avec ce crâne non plus
suivant et au passage vous insultez les
populations amérindiennes en appelant sa
un crâne non-humains bande de connards
voilà je tenais à faire savoir que c'est
aussi racistes ces théories là
évidemment une organisation sans but non
lucratif nommé starchild project remis
le crâne à laboratoire britannique où il
subit une analyse détaillée son adn
cette étude conclut qu'il s'agit d'un
être humain sans autre commentaire
ben parce qu'il a rien d'autre à dire
c'est un être humain je veux dire le
déjà de base déjà de base l'anatomie et
humaine donc si l'adn en plus est humain
il n'y a pas plus de commentaires à
faire
seuls trois photos attestant de
l'existence de ce crâne circulent
aujourd'hui sur internet
bah ouais bah c'est déjà pas mal non va
chercher sur google scholar ya peut-être
une public en 1880 plusieurs crânes
humains avec des protubérances tels des
cornes osseuse ont été découverts dans
un monticule de serre dans le côté de
bahts forme de bradford en pennsylvanie
excepté les excroissances osseuses
située sur le front les hommes à qui ces
squelettes ont appartenu
tu es anatomiquement normes on a estimé
que le corps a été enterré sur des dieux
vers 1200 ans avant jésus-christ la
découverte est due à docteur 2,9 ou
historiens deux professeurs de the
american investing museum ça sent la sas
en l'institution sérieuse américaine
investigate thing museum moorhead
philips blabla massachussetts les
craintes de cette exceptionnelle
découvertes ont des découverts ont été
envoyés à l'américaine investing museum
philadelphia il aurait été volé dans le
musée même disparaissant à tout jamais
comme la plupart des artefacts qui
remettent en cause les théories
officielles anthropologique alors
américaine investing museum of
philadelphia
solution va déjà c'est ce qui est
inquiétant c'est que je le trouve pas ce
cet american investigate hing muséum est
inconnu au bataillon il n'a pas de page
wikipédia il a pas de page internet il
ya rien du tout donc donc donc il n'a
pas d'adressé parce que même google maps
le trouve pas donc je dis pas que ce qui
n'existe pas sur google n'existe pas
tout court mais mais quand même si on le
trouve pas sur google c'est quand même
chiant
évidemment les premières références
qu'on trouve c'est sur ce fameux crâne
bah voilà donc le américaine investing
museum inconnu au bataillon donc pareil
il suffit de vérifier de seconde
il n'y a pas de napa de napa d'adressent
n'existe pas voilà un césar n'a
non je dis ça je dis ces arnaques parce
que ça ça c'est l'arrière d'un crâne de
vache
voilà ça c'est celle ariane d'akranes de
vache qu'on essaye de faire passer pour
un crâne d'extraterrestres j'imagine une
fois de plus donc ça c'est juste la
pneumatique nation qu'il ya en dessous
des cornes du crâne de la vache ça c'est
l'arrière du crâne et là c'est le trou
occipital qu'on a rempli avec un os
voilà c'est tout ça se voit au premier
coup d'oeil
c'est formidable ça c'est alors ça c'est
marrant parce que c'est une vraie
anomalie en fait si je me rappelle bien
il ya vraiment des maladies qui qui fait
ça voilà il ya une maladie qui fait ça
donc ça les lapins il ya cet animal
mythique qu'on appelle un jackalope qui
à lapin avec des cornes mais en fait si
vous tapez disease donc pour maladie ben
voila vous trouvez vraiment qu'il ya une
maladie qui créent des excroissances de
7 sur la tronche et qui peut
effectivement faire ressembler à un
lapin jackalope donc c'est pas non plus
complètement impossible
c'est dégueulasse 1 je le conçois c'est
absolument horrible comme maladie mais
mais c'est une maladie ça existe bel et
bien donc vous voyez là quand il faut
focaliser sur la tête basse à peu faire
ressembler le lapin un jackalope donc
c'est pas non plus impossible bon après
la le crâne le crâne dont qui parle bas
ça vient d'un institut qui apparemment
n'existe pas mais même comme il ya comme
comme il a bizarrement disparu bon saura
jamais si c'était un vrai ou un faux
seins et ce qui est marrant c'est que
comme il dit lui même
ils disparaissent à tout jamais comme la
plupart des actifs acquis romaine la
théorie officielle de l'anthropologie
bla bla bla donc théorie du appel à la
théorie du complot sauf que cette
théorie du complot que la retourner dans
l'autre sens il fait une affirmation sur
un crâne avec des cornes
moi je serais super intéressé de le voir
parce que j'aimerais bien savoir si ces
camps ne sont vrais ou pas parce que si
c'est des vrais quand [ __ ] ça
révolutionne pas mal de choses
effectivement
et quand on lui demande on peut le voir
ce crâne non il a disparu
il est allé dans un musée qu'on connaît
pas que même google scholar connaît que
même google maps connaît pas et il a
disparu
abadie dons
c'est dommage quand même hein donc voilà
c'est comme par hasard toutes ces
preuves accablantes que la théorie de
l'évolution est fausse elles
disparaissent et comme ça en bas on peut
plus on peut plus les étudier on peut
pas voir si c'est vrai ou pas on peut
pas voir si c'est du fake bizarre bon et
puis ça c'est un crâne avec c'est juste
de l'hydro de l'hydrocéphalie ça c'est
assez le pauvre crâne d'un enfant malade
ça monsieur
rien à voir avec des extraterrestres ou
que ou des reptiliens donc les crânes
ont été photographiés par robert
connolly au cours de voyages autour du
monde alors qu'ils recueillaient des
informations au sujet des civilisations
anciennes la découverte de ces crânes de
forme inhabituelle fonds pour ainsi dire
un résultat inattendu de son travail
non non non ça c'est ça c'est pas
inattendue ça c'est pas inattendu si tu
enlèves la phase un crâne bas ça ça a
disparu et puis voilà ça c'est pas
inattendu c'est ce que simone
hydrocéphale en 1995 robert connolly a
publié ses photographies sur cd-rom
intitulé the search for death and wind
wisdom étant donné le peu de
renseignements au sujet de ces crânes
il est difficile de déterminer leur âge
leurs rapports avec d'autres hominidés
ainsi que leur emplacement d'origine
dans une chronologie certains crânes
sont si différents de ceux que nous
connaissons qu'ils pourraient appartenir
à une toute autre espèce qui
présenteraient une lointaine
ressemblance avec le genre humain
connolly distingue quatre groupes de
crâne en fonction de leur forme le type
gie jack o'lantern nommé à la citrouille
ainsi qu ainsi que pour la lanterne
d'halloween donc j'imagine que c'est les
crânes hydrocéphale le type m nommé à
cause de la forme de ce crâne très
particulier voilà on n'a pas dit s à 1
heure heure voit aucune figure donc on
sait pas lequel des quatre et le type m
le type pré moderne crâne au blond
considéré comme plus ancien parc only de
façon arbitraire je suppose et le type
c'est est en forme de cône
bah ouais
les crâne allongé donc quelle est la
différence entre le connais le houblon
du coup j'aurais bien aimé voir à
battants tiens on va voir le cra le type
de crâne j en forme de lanternes pose
plusieurs problèmes c'est un équivalent
du type moderne sous tous les rapports
avec plusieurs éléments hors de
proportion le moins significatif et la
taille des orbites qui est d'environ 15%
plus grande que chez les populations
modernes le plus important et l'énormité
de la voûte crânienne la capacité de la
boîte crânienne entre 2600 et 3200
centimètres cubes l'âge du spécimen est
inconnu et jusqu'à présent pas d'autres
spécimens de ce genre n'a été nommé donc
en gros il ya quinze spécimens et ça
ressemble évidemment à une pote à une
pathologie donc je vais dire pourquoi ne
pas conclure que c'est une pathologie
and on attend c'est le type j donc en
plus y'a pas d'image du type gillon bien
le crâne m est encore plus bizarre que
le précédent il est incomplet au niveau
de la partie inférieure de la zone
faciale après les restes de la partie
faciale on constate que ces
caractéristiques ne varie pas par
rapport à un crâne humain classique
cependant il possède une voûte crânienne
la plus grande de tous les spécimens
connu de connolly les deux lobes en
saillie sont également anormaux la façon
quasi certaine à plus de 3000
centimètres cubes les types gm sont
proches de l'impossibilité biologique et
c'est pour ça qu'il en a qu'un en tout
cas pour le dj c'est peut-être le crâne
de quelqu'un qui est mort parce que
c'était une pathologie selon connolly la
seule manière d'expliquer leur grosseur
et d'émettre l'hypothèse de la néoténie
la capacité de l'espèce a prolongé la
croissance avant d'arriver à maturité
des deux groupes
cette étendue au delà de celle du type
moderne mais pourquoi pas la pathologie
pourquoi vous voulez pourquoi vous allez
me déterré néoténie pour ce qui est
évidemment une pathologie je veux dire
vous a vécu qu'un crâne vous avec un
crâne et si en plus c'est un enfant je
veux dire si ça c'est le type gie c'est
quoi ce en forme de lanternes ah oui
d'accord ok je viens de comprendre donc
le type jc en forme de lanternes
c'est un crâne hydrocéphale c'est une
pathologie et je sais tout pourquoi vous
allez chercher des néoténie je veux dire
les suppositions selon lesquelles il
s'agirait de simple déformation de cas
pathologiques peuvent difficilement ce
jeu se justifier parmi les populations
humaines actuelles on rencontre de temps
en temps des craintes présentant des
anomalies de croissance ou des formats
normal mais c'est ma formation reste des
valeurs restent dans les valeurs de
l'espèce de riffs
ans c'est ça ton argument c'est ça ton
argument pour dire que pour rejeter la
pathologie c'est juste que ouais mais ça
ressemble quand même à un humain bah oui
ça aussi ça ressemble quand même à un
humain et puis ça aussi ça ressemble je
veux dire si tu t'arrêtes la voilà que
tu observes que ça c'est tout humain il
ya juste une pathologie à ce niveau là
c'est une pathologie du développement
sur un crâne qui est évidemment celui
d'un juvénile quand tu vois la future
qui est là donc c'est quelqu'un qui a
pas vécu très longtemps donc c'est une
voie là il ya tout indique que c'est une
pathologie quoi selon les textes
médicaux local le plus grand avait une
capacité de 1981 centimètres cubes
oui le cas le crâne le plus grand normal
mais il était de forme normale
voilà j'ai même pas eu à lire jusque là
pour savoir qu'il était normal il ne
faut pas oublier que toute croissance
pathologie du crâne a presque toujours
des conséquences fatales oui bah il
al'air vivant lui connard [ __ ] pour
l'individu et ce à tout début du
développement la nature n'ont pas
forcément tout début du développement il
ya des enfants hydrocéphales qui
naissent et qui vivent encore quelque
temps après je veux dire la nature est
très a pitoyablement était garé tous les
spécimens présentés ici étaient des
individus d'âge mûr
c'est cela oui comme un test 7
cette future absolument gigantesque la
capacité de la voûte crânienne et par
conséquent la masse du cerveau n'est pas
nécessairement lié à l'intelligence ça
n'a rien à voir je vois pas en quoi est
ce que tu viens de dire avant démontre
ça n'est pas nécessairement lié à
l'intelligence l'individu le plus grand
crâne connu était un homme retardée
alors ce vocabulaire ce vocabulaire du
xviiie siècle mystère des crânes pré
moderne et conique type c'est quand les
images de ce crâne furent présentés en
1996 sa magie la majorité des gens a
supposé être en présence d'un cas de
tête bandée une une mode connu pour être
pratiquée par l'ancienne nubie en egypte
et dans d'autres cultures le problème
posé par cette théorie est que les
crânes bien allongé pourvu d'un front
aplati incliné vers l'arrière ont la
même capacité qu un crâne humain
classique
bah oui parce que le
parce que le cerveau ils changent pas de
volume la seule différence est la forme
obtenu après des formations frontale et
latérale par ailleurs on ne rencontre
pas de crâne en forme de cône parmi les
crânes bande est courant robert connolly
pense de manière assez catégorique il
n'est pas en présence de cas isolés de
pathologies crânienne et on ne saura
jamais pourquoi à ou peut-être que si
connolly analyse ces découvertes en ces
termes la partie frontale des crânes pré
modernes semblent appartenir à un
individu de la famille dit prêt en herbe
talât valait que la mâchoire inférieure
bien plus robuste que le type dits de
l'homme moderne possède une forme des
caractéristiques modernes la forme de la
boîte crânienne ne possède aucune
similitude avec les types et rictus et
néandertal ni avec le type de l'homme
moderne certaines caractéristiques
mineurs ne des rentes et elles sont
présentes telles que la capitale
derrière actuelle comprise
ceci n'est pas surprenant là je saute
pas ce que je sais c'est technique c'est
qu'à ce pied étant donné les derniers
hommes de néandertal et dernier en
moderne avait une boîte crânienne plus
grande la réduction de la capacité la
boîte crânienne spécimens datant
d'environ mille et une questions à notre
mister également leur a expliqué comment
un représentant de type moderne à temps
elle s'arrête où la citation là elle
s'arrête là d'accord parce que là on
dirait que c'est plus l'auteur de
l'article qui écrit ça que connolly
également du mal à expliquer comment un
représentant de type de l'homme
prémoderne se retrouve sur le continent
sud américain buy a dit milan support un
réduction de la capacité de la boîte
crânienne d'ailleurs soudaine les boîtes
crâniennes des spécimens date d'environ
10000 ans sont plus petites est une
question mystérieuse autre mystère on a
également du mal à expliquer comment un
représentant du type dits de l'homme
moderne se retrouve sur le continent sud
américain
bah oui mais je dis mille cinq cents ans
et il y avait déjà des y avait déjà des
paléo indien donc c'est pas un problème
selon l'anthropologie orthodoxe ce crâne
n'existe pas purement et simplement car
cela ne se peut pas les textes
établissent la plus vieille date
d'apparition dumars en amérique à 35
mille ans avant jésus-christ bah oui
enfin déjà 35 mille ans avant
jésus-christ non j'imagine que ce texte
est très ancien
en 96 c'est ça il date de 96 35 milles
en ont maintenant on est plutôt sur
quinze mille ans mais enfin dix mille
ans ça reste notre honnête je veux dire
non et a beaucoup plus tard pour
l'amérique du sud selon les hypothèses
la théorie de la diffusion les seuls
types humains dont on admet les à
présent sur le continent et une anatomie
moderne il existe d'autres sources qui
place tous les types de genre humain
dans les deux amériques et les dates
beaucoup plus anciens d'après de
nombreuses découvertes mais
officiellement on s'en tient à ces
données mais c'est à dire que c'est
juste par rapport à des proportions de
la boîte crânienne c'est quoi ça c'est
en plus bas à temps je vais je vais
terminer ça mais je vais revenir sur
cette photo là après la pause que
j'aille voir un truc mais là donc il ya
des similitudes avec erectus et
néandertal c'est donc là est occipital
et machin truc
bah ouais enfin il ya un crâne d'humains
en gros qui a dit milan avec une boîte
crânienne de 1600 centimètres cubes ce
qui reste dans la gamme de variation de
l'homme moderne la moyenne est
effectivement à 1400 aider mais bon 1600
centimètres ça reste dans la gamme de
variation le crâne à dix mille ans donc
c'est pas je veux dire c'est encore un
humain qui est vieux de dix mille ans je
veux dire c'est pas un humain moderne
moderne donc voir des différences c'est
pas non plus la fin du monde je veux
dire pourquoi tout de suite allé
chercher tout pourquoi tout de suite
allé chercher la théorie du complot là
encore une fois c'est le crâne n'existe
pas là non mais c'est ça c'est non bon
il ya un humain moderne avec quelques
caractéristiques étrange c'est pas non
plus la fin du monde
il n'y a rien qu'on ne puisse pas
expliqué bon je reviens sur ce crâne la
crânes d'hommes hydrocéphale morts à
marseille
en 1616 âgé de 50 ans voilà donc le mec
il nous montre des crânes pathologique
donc ça c'est pas pathologique ça c'est
une vraie race
reptilien qui s'est éteint et ça c'est
un crâne pathologique
les pathologies dont il parlait tout à
l'heure ils disent il disait c'est pas
des pathologies parce que
c'est des gens qui ont acquis sont d'un
âge mûr
voilà donc sous-entendu si c'était une
pathologie ce ne serait que des gens
jeunes
or la pathologie crânienne hommes
atteints d'hydrocéphalie mort à 50 ans
moi je dis ça je dis rien
j'ai juste voilà la phrase elle est là
la phrase aller au dessus l'image elle
est là le gars qui a écrit l'article n'a
pas fait la connexion
je veux dire pourquoi tu mets tout ça
dans le même article je veux dire qu'il
y avait du coup tu admets que ce sont
des pathologies c'est ça je ne comprends
pas bref trois spécimens de type c'est
robert connolly a découvert trois crânes
de type ses plus bas figurent un plus
bas dans la région de parra k donc voilà
les fameux crâne avec la morphologie
allonger le type dit en forme de cône
est très inhabituel quand la forme de
boîte crânienne le fait d'en avoir
trouvé 3 exclu l'éventualité d'une
déformation accidentelle oui comme je
les dis c'était une déformation
volontaire il ne fait aucun doute qu'ils
sont étroitement liés et il se peut
qu'il représente une branche tout à fait
distincte du genre humain voire une
espèce totalement différente où on a
volontairement déformé des crânes à
trois personnes qui n'ont pas forcément
de lien de parenté
moi je dis ça 1 toutes les proportions
générales des trois crânes sont
harmonieuses la grandeur des voûte
crânienne et manifestent on peut estimer
le volume à 2000 2500 centimètres cubes
des représentants moderne des craintes
de connolly des roms robert considère
que les craintes de type c est pré
moderne sur le type humanoïdes inconnu
ce n'est pas tout à fait exact en ce qui
concerne ces deux types une comparaison
est possible avec des êtres de chair et
d'os qui vécurent sur notre planète le
type c est comparable à une statue du
louvre représentant à dieu quant au type
pré moderne et s'apparente au statut
égyptien néfertiti il ne peut s'agir
d'une des formations liées à une
pathologie crânienne plusieurs
générations représente rigoureusement
les mêmes caractéristiques il ne s'agit
pas non plus d'un effet de style de
sculptures marquant la lignée des
pharaons les crânes en témoigne d'autre
part les grandes coiffe de l'egypte du
xviiie siècle couvre bien de grand crâne
qui ont peu de choses en commun avec le
crâne dit de l'homme moderne
akhenaton était-il un humain non mais
c'est un chapeau veut ça c'est un
chapeau et puis ça mais c'est une
sculpture et puis même si je veux dire
mais encore falloir que j'aille chercher
des trucs comme ça non mais c'est pas
vrai donc skull des formations ovale on
va dire artificial coloniale des
formations donc on peut aller voir même
sur wikipédia 1 il ya un article
wikipédia à propos de ça et alors on va
montrer on va montrer voilà oui il y
avait des êtres de chair et de sang qui
se déforme et le crâne comme ça voilà il
en voici un exemple ici voilà là encore
il ya un exemple de personnes qui ont
vécu un ca la colonisation que les
européens ont interdit cette pratique
parce que autrement ils le feraient
encore les gens c'est arrivé à la
colonisation voyez il y avait des
populations africaines y avait des
populations sud-américaine qu'il faisait
régulièrement et puis c'est la
colonisation à la colonisation on a dit
aux gens d'arrêter
voilà mais sinon voyez il ya des ya même
des photos couleurs de gens qui se sont
déformés le crâne comme ça donc c'est
pas voilà et ce sont des êtres humains
le dire vous allez vous allez les voir
pour leur dire que ce sont pas des êtres
humains
regardez nope on met des bandage autour
de la tête du bébé puis ça donne un
crâne au blond il ya même des voiliers
il ya même des articles sur des
personnes moderne et là vous voyez de
l'article wikipédia donc qui vous
explique tout ça donc je vous laisse
aller voir l'article wikipédia vous
pouvez les mettre en français si vous
voulez voilà on peut même le mettre en
français et mais c'est quand même
terrible ça de padt d'avoir aucune
considération pour les cultures
différentes de la sienne
c'est ouf quand même donc non il n'y a
pas un qui n'a t-on c'était un humain
oui l'a juste fait il a juste fait ce
que ces gens là font voilà du bandage
autour de la tête et c'est parti du
bandage autour de la tête quand ton
crâne est encore plastique kanté bébé et
puis c'est parti
statue d'akhénaton au musée du caire est
très instructive elle révèle un crâne
énorme sous la coiffe du pharaon l'année
à comparer aux standards symboliser
l'homme de vitruve voilà l'homme de
vitruve c'est devenu une référence
maintenant ta gueule la taille des très
hautes le vent très volumineux les bras
les jambes les biceps et triceps mollet
sont maigres sans aucun rapport avec la
musculature d'un homme ordinaire mais
c'est une sculpture
deux ne veut dire il ya une licence
encore une fois il ya des licences
artistique
il avait une esthétique les egyptiens
ils avaient ils voulaient pas que les
gens ils voulaient que les statuts
reflète cette esthétique
vous avez une culture aussi voulait pas
forcément faire des sculptures réaliste
il ya qu'à la renaissance qu'on a
commencé à faire des peintures et des
sculptures réaliste avant ça on les
faisait pas facile peut-être la grèce
antique mais même la grèce antique
c'était décor idéalisé qui étaient
représentés dont je veux dire [ __ ]
voilà il ya des licences artistique
derrière les sculptures bref la largeur
des hanches aussi large que les épaules
cette physionomie si particulière se
retrouve chez néfertiti et ses fils se
doit d'avoir fait une répartition
harmonieuse des proportions qui ne sont
pas comparables aux standards humain ce
qui veut pas dire que c'est pas basé sur
un humain nous affirmons que pendant la
xviiie dynastie d'autres époques une
race très différente de l'homme dirigé
l'égypte par les deux pharaons comme
d'un dieu naître n'est pas n'être pas
pur hasard d'un dieu naître le pop ur de
réseau se retrouvait face à un être de
ce type devait être impressionnant
suscitant peur et respect c'est vrai que
considère considérer nos dirigeants
comme des dieux on n'a jamais fait ça
surtout pas en france surtout pas la
monarchie absolue aux nounous nounoune
ont considéré que le nôtre dirigeant
était de pouvoir divin ça n'est jamais
arrivé
jamais jamais louis xiv était un
extra-terrestre aussi ou un reptilien je
sais pas on sait par conséquent tu as
déjà vu lui 14 t'as déjà vu lui 14 tu as
vu qu'il était paré petit lien voilà si
comme le dit connolly des crânes qu'il
nomme pré moderne fut retrouvée au pérou
et au tibet c'est que la race
d'akhenaton fut dominante dans ces
régions à la même époque où entre eux ou
en d'autres temps comme s'il s'agit
d'une race dite divine par les hommes
d'alors ses facultés supérieures lui ont
permis de dominer le monde des hommes
sur tout les continents à une certaine
époque les engins volants décrit par les
textes sacrés amérindiens vient vais
dicter bêta ou égyptiens honte très bien
pu être le moyen de cette race usa
pourvoyeur dont cette race usa pour
voyager et prendre en main la destinée
de la race humaine
ça c'est s'agit-il de la face aquatique
de jeu
des vaisseaux spatiaux mais ouais tu
pourrais nous montrer des photos de thé
vaisseaux spatiaux la bastille moi je me
rappelle d'un soi-disant vaisseau
spatial égyptien s'est en fait de
hiéroglyphes superposés alors voilà le
mystère aujourd'hui est de savoir ce
qu'il advint de cette race différente de
l'humain ordinaire non le mystère c'est
d'arriver à dire mais vous comment tu as
fini sur cette conclusion là avec ces
données là le dire comment tu es parti
de là pour conclure ça enfin pour
conclure ça la vie extraterrestre non
c'est ça le vrai mystère demeure tel
cachet dirigeants en coulisses la
géopolitique de notre monde contemporain
vous pourquoi nous cache-t-on son
existence qui est nous qui est nous qui
vous cache son existence c'est pas ce ce
qui est certain c'est que c'est qu'une
certaine élite mondiale nous cache
sciemment des artefacts et antiquités
essentiellement pour connaître notre
lointain passé
pourquoi c'est vrai ça pourquoi moi
j'aimerais bien savoir pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi on ferait ça pour quelles
raisons
pour quelles raisons obscures est ce
qu'on ferait ça à une autre façon de
détecter un bon article bullshit sait
aussi qu'il termine par des questions
qui n'ont rien à voir avec ce qui est au
dessus c'est à dire que ce qui a au
dessus on nous démontre tout au plus qui
a des crânes qui qui sont un peu trop
bizarre pour être humain d'après
l'auteur pas pour moi pour moi on est
face à des pathologies et à des
déformations volontaire et tout au plus
le seul crâne un peu mystérieux c'est
celui-là mais bon je peux tout à fait
admettre qu'il y a une maladie qui fait
ça je suis pas médecin
mais voilà là où on reconnaît le bon
article bullshit voyait c'est sur les
questions qu'ils soulèvent à la fin le
mystère reste entier rappelez vous tout
bord tout bon bullshit termine par le
mystère reste entier
hélas hélas on envoie du lourd là des
grosses questions qui ne sont absolument
pas lié à l'article
genre pourquoi on nous la cache pourquoi
on nous l'a caché est ce que c'est
quelque chose de d'évoquer qu'on nous
cache quelque chose déjà dans l'article
rapidement éventuellement il ya
peut-être une phrase dessus
éventuellement voilà la géopolitique de
notre monde dirigé par des reptiliens
est ce que c'est quelque chose de
d'évoquer dans l'arctique donc non
injuste non donc voilà juste de la merde
là c'est bull shit bullshit bullshit
donc ça c'est une autre façon de
reconnaître un bon article bullshit les
questions alors là c'est toujours c'est
alors je vous envoie c'est vers cette
source après tout je veux pas pourquoi
là je sors church and wisdom vous pouvez
aller voir toutes ces magnifiques photos
qui sont certainement passionnante déjà
déjà déjà si on prend encore principe
que ça c'est censé être les quatre cas
les plus percutants bah c'est pas gagné
1 voilà et puis ça c'est juste une photo
d'un ami d'euros céphalées il nous l'a
dit donc voilà les proportions machin et
on passe maintenant à la préhistoire
voilà un petit peu de préhistoire pour
terminer le tout alors finalement les
dinosauriens serait-il le peuple
dégénéré et corrompu et même les
atlantes où les titans détruit
finalement par le grand déluge décrit
dans beaucoup de textes et certains
n'aurait-il pas survécu finalement pour
accompagner l'humanité dans sa création
ou réapparition à leur avantage
il ya un autre truc qui est fait à ton
avantage cellule usage des chronologies
parce que le grand déluge mixer le grand
déluge biblique avec des dinosaures rien
fait
voilà merci la chronologie même des
scientifiques et des médias s'en mêlent
et trouve les choses dès les choses de
la préhistoire présenté officiellement
comme sûres comme étant en fait très
tronqué et visible avec des oeillères
n'y a rien sur ans en sciences il ya des
hypothèses qui tiennent mieux que
d'autres
éventuellement mai
rien de sûr après si tu veux parler de
hier on va reparler du paragraphe du
dessus là par contre préhistoire cro
magnon n'a jamais fait la révolution
hunt de salles quitte le débat sur
l'évolution de l'homme rebondi avec des
découvertes troublantes et des
scientifiques à l'esprit critique
parmi les découvertes un crâne
d'ailleurs très ancienne découvert en
mongolie photo à gauche
sa datation récente au au plus 30 mille
ans montrent qu'ils traversent les
frontières mise depuis longtemps entre
l'homme moderne cro magnon ou même et
nos ancêtres autre découverte ces traces
d'activités culturelles et de
technologies très ancienne des dizaines
de milliers d'un des dizaines de
milliers d'années et pourtant des
allures modernes qui rives relativise la
réputation de révolutionnaire de cro
magnon
je comprends pas parce que un crâne
d'homme moderne en mongolie à 30 30
mille ans est pas révolutionnaire du
tout l'homme moderne il est l'homme
moderne donc de cro magnon est sorti de
et sortis d'afrique il ya cent mille ans
il ya entre 100000 et 80 mille ans donc
je vois pas où est le problème de
trouver un homme moderne en mongolie à
30 mille ans las il a une fois de plus
si on savait d'où vient cette citation
là on pourrait éventuellement en faire
quelque chose mais là c'est pareil on
sait pas d'où elle vient cette citation
donc suivant j'ai publié vendredi
dernier dans libération un article fondé
sur un reportage à toulouse
le voici ci-dessous agrémenté de liens
et d'image qui n'ont pas trouvé place
dans le journal vendu en kiosque pardon
j'ai publié vendredi dernier dans
libération avait mais du coup ils
parlent de il parle de cette hauteur là
c'est ça de frédéric morin qui a publié
dans libération j'aimerais bien savoir
bref je sais pas du coup on sait pas de
qui il parle comme c'est mal présentés
bref toulouse envoyé spécial regarder ce
crâne archaïque non regardez ce crâne
point archaïque non un air de néandertal
voir d'homo erectus voyez ces arcades
sourcilières proéminente se feront bar
rejetée en arrière
josé braga arbore un sourire malicieux
assis dans un bureau dans son bureau de
l'université paul sabatier il tient en
main un moulages de crânes actuellement
présenté au public un crâne très
incomplet réduit à sa partie supérieure
comme si l'on avait sabré l'homme de
haut niveau des yeux puis découpé à
l'horizontale et le nous et le montre en
soulignant à plaisir son allure
archaïques selon les critères habituels
permettant de le séparer du moderne
autrement dit cro magnon ou voir ou
votre voisin de palier donc maintenant
ce crâne finalement c'est plus un cro
magnon ses avants cro magnon donc c'est
un crâne qui serait plus primitif que
cro magnon donc un homo heidelbergensis
mais c'est pareil homo heidelbergensis
il est sorti d'afrique aussi à ce moment
là l'homo erectus d'asie il existait
encore il ya cinquante mille ans bon à
la limite si celui-là trente mille ans
ce n'est peut-être pas un homo erectus
mais ça peut encore être un homo
heidelbergensis on a encore retrouvé un
crâne domeizel bergin 6 relativement
récent en chine y'a pas longtemps
donc c'est pas si étonnant que ça
d'avoir de l'homo heidelbergensis et
homo heidelbergensis avait effectivement
le front un peu en arrière comme ça et
les gros sourcils et les gros bourgs les
supras orbitaire donc oui il est un peu
jeune pour un homo heidelbergensis je
veux bien faire confiance à josé braga
dont josé braga qui est entre
paléoanthropologue à toulouse non plus
au moins ce que je sais que ce qu'ils
disent est pas de la connerie
donc je veux bien lui faire confiance
sur le fait que ça à 30 mille ans et que
effectivement si c'est au niveau et
dahlberg n 6
c'est vachement jeunes pour de l'homo
heidelbergensis mais on sait pas non
plus complètement inattendu quoi ou
alors ça pourrait aussi être denisot va
parce que denisot va on sait qu'il est
proche de néandertal on sait qu il
existait aussi il ya trente mille ans ou
qui devait exister dans ses parages
parce qu'évidemment on n'a pas beaucoup
de faux cils donc il est possible aussi
que ce soit un crâne d'une espèce proche
de denisot va voir de denisova même donc
c'est pas non plus complètement
inattendu contrairement aux kamoulox là
que vous j'ai rien compris à ce que ça
voulait dire là déjà ça fait un peu plus
ce sens voyez et quand ça fait un peu
plus ce sens on peut réfléchir
sereinement
on peut réfléchir sereinement donc là
peut-être contient quelque chose de très
intéressant effectivement une petite
calotte crânienne de quelque chose qui
serait proche de denisova ou de
néandertal et qui aurait vécu en asie il
ya trente mille ans lorsque ce crâne est
découvert en 2006 dans une steppe
glacial et désolé du nord-est de la
mongolie sur le site de salles creed et
par les prospecteurs d'or clandestins
ces derniers se disent qu'ils ont trouvé
un objet vraiment anciens donc de valeur
de l'or pur scientifiques ils le vendent
illico à des paléoanthropologues
m'engueule ces derniers contacts yves
coppens le célèbre co découvreur de la
lointaine cousine de l'australopithèque
lucy et personne ne doutait alors que ce
vestige suis très anciens lorsque braga
cnrs fut de fut alertée par coppa ce
dernier lui confia l'objet en estimant
qu'il s'agissait de représentants
archaïque de l'humanité donc homo
heidelbergensis dans l'article paru en
février 2008
yves coppens et ses co signataires
évoquent même outre sapiens archaïque
qui à la faveur du titre néandertal et
la filière homo erectus chinois pour
qualifier ce fossile bas ça tombe bien
on a les mêmes conclusions
mais avec la physique nucléaire les
datations viennent compléter les
analyses morphologiques ou géologiques
poursuivre poursuivi par josé braga yves
coppens et d'autres spécialistes sur le
site de s'inscrite josé braga ni donc
mais josé braga c'est lui voilà un
minuscule morceau de crâne étudié au
carbone 14 dans un laboratoire américain
en floride a donné une date de 21000 à
vingt-deux mille ans une autre étude en
cours avec des moyens plus performants
pourraient le vieillir mais au plus 30
mille ans affirme josé braga conclusion
l'homme de s'inscrite est donc un homme
à sapiens sapiens comme nous alors ça ça
c'est un peu rapide comme conclusion
juste par la date finalement c'est la
sapiens non ça peut être un homo
heidelbergensis qui a survécu jusqu'à
trente mille ans la date
une datation ne fait pas une phylogénie
ça c'est une erreur qui est assez
commune
quand on parle de paléoanthropologie de
confondre une date avec avec une
attribution mais bon si on si le sillage
jeunes de ce crâne fait de lui un homo
sapiens ça veut dire que aumône ali dit
aussi est à sapiens et homo naledi fait
à m 62 à quoi donc
il fait un mètre soixante deux ans il a
la capacité crânienne
d'un chimpanzé donc faut pas non plus
faut pas non plus trop élaborer et c'est
pareil pour
l'homme de florès veut dire donc non
c'est pas parce que c'est pas parce qu'à
quelque chose des jeunes qu'il est
forcément sapiens je veux dire toutes
les espèces qui vivent en même temps que
nous aujourd'hui ne sont pas des homo
sapiens juste parce qu'elles vivent en
même temps que nous donc faut pas
confondre phylogénie et date
donc c'est quelque chose qui est assez
commun dans canton dans la littérature
de vulgarisation scientifique quand on
parle de dévolution de l'homme faut
faire attention à ça l'âge n'est pas la
phylogénie une phylogénie c'est
complètement différent ça peut être une
branche tardive dowell dahlberg n 6 qui
a survécu
la variabilité morphologie de notre
espèce est sous-estimée ce qui veut dire
aussi que la conception que l'on a de
ces relations de parenté avec neandertal
et homo erectus pourrait être rené trop
vu sous l'angle d'une violente coupure
la limite je suis d'accord
l'anthropologue il est professeur à
l'université toulouse donc là je suppose
qu'on arrête la citation est un
spécialiste ès morphologie humaine
là je sens que ça va faire appel à de
l'argument d'autorité de derrière les
fagots
à de l'image médicale c'est un virtuose
de la reconstitution
oui l aide des données numérisées danse
actuelle les fossiles informatique et 7
ans biologiste donc amoureux de darwin
de l'évolution et la variabilité qu'il
aborde son sujet favori celle de l'homme
oui et donc tu vas te servir de
l'autorité de josé braga tu vas salir
l'autorité de josé braga
j'ai même envie de dire pour pourquoi
pour servir ton propre argument qui est
lui-même anti évolutionniste mais va
lire tous les articles de josé braga va
lire toute la littérature tous les
bouquins qu'il a écrit josé braga et
après tu reviendras pour cause et voilà
après tu reviendras nous parler de
l'amour que tu as pour la pour
l'autorité de josé braga 1 au lieu de
prendre juste un bout d'article sortie
de son contexte de la bordel de merde
une variabilité trop souvent occultée
dans la pensée des anthropologues
or souligne elle est occulté mais c'est
pour ça que josé braga en parle d'un
connard
or souligne-t-il la vraie dimension du
volume du cerveau de sapia ce n'est pas
1400 canonique devant lesquels devraient
s'incliner année rictus à 1000 cm cube
chez les bushmen d'afrique australe on
trouve des individus très proche du
fameux mais désormais désuet rubicon
cérébrale vers 800 cm cube sens aînés
c'est sensé nécessaires à la pensée
complexe 7 entre 800 et 2000 centimètre
cube que se situent les crânes de
sapiens sapiens est rien rien là de la
distance dans entre un imbécile est
super intelligent puisque anatole france
affichait à peine plus de 1600
centimètres cubes
je ne suis pas sûr quand même que les
bushmen descend jusqu'à 800 cm cube
mais bon après les bushmen souvent ils
sont pas super bien nourris dont ils ont
une petite stature donc encore une fois
faut ramener ses centimètres cubes à la
taille du corps et là on sait pas quelle
est la taille du corps de ceux bushmen
qui a un crâne de 8 centimètres cubes
s'il tentait qu'il existe donc voilà
c'est encore une fois la taille
c'est à ça que sert le coefficient dans
ses valises à sion c'est à ramener tous
à la taille du corps quoi à cet exemple
classique l'anthropologue ajoute ses
propres travaux sur le sur le
développement des dans une étude récente
menée à l'aide du synchrotron sur les
dents de dix jeunes néandertaliens et
sapiens fossiles veut démontrer que les
premiers devenait adulte plus vite il
rétorque que l'âge de l'émergence des
premières molaires permanente varie de
ce 4 à 7 ans dans les populations
actuelles et lance je suis certain que
dans des collections anatomie du muséum
on trouverait des individus aux allures
néandertalienne en tout cas très proche
de certains fossiles qualifié de
néandertaliens oui pour ce caractère là
pas en général pas dans son anatomie
général pour ce caractère dentaire
particulier encore une fois sorti de
contexte que cherche à faire josé braga
en et forçant ainsi à petits coups
d'ironie les frontières soigneusement
posé entre l'espèce humaine et décennie
par décennie d'anthropologie tout
simplement à soutenir la messe n'est pas
dite
quant aux relations de parenté entre
formes humainement ça c'est toi qui
essaye de faire ça josé braga il est
réaliste sur la variabilité d'homo
sapiens toi tu toi tu essayes de
brouiller les pistes c'est pas pareil
que la vulgate d'une population d'homo
sapiens surgissent brusquement d'afrique
il est environ 200 millions 100 mille
ans pas de cent mille ans la sortie
d'afrique et n'ayant connu aucune
relation sexuelle reproductive avec
d'autres groupes c'est pas vrai
maintenant on le sait qui a eu des
relations sexuelles avec d'autres
espèces n'est pas la fin de l'histoire
de nos ancêtres que la découverte de
faibles traces d adn spécifiquement
nordique aliens dans les populations
humaines indiquent plutôt que les
frontières entre ces groupes n'étaient
pas totalement hermétique oui mais ça on
le sait mon bon ami
c'est là tu fais comme si les
scientifiques étaient pas au courant
mais les scientifiques sont au courant
c'est pas c'est pas un problème c'est
pas une révolution on sait bien que le
concept même d'espèce est complètement
arbitraire mais ça c'est pareil t'as pas
l'air d'intégrer sa part contre ras ce
genre espèce n'a pas l'air de bien
intégrer mais tout ça là tous ces unités
taxonomique sont arbitraires totalement
arbitraire donc oui on sait que
toute unité taxonomique arbitraire a ses
limites fatalement puisqu'elle est
arbitraire ces temps préhistoriques un
spécialiste de l'industrie lithique la
taille du silex le principal témoin de
danse est que teyssandier de qui vient
de dons qui lui aussi est un est un
scientifique donc du laboratoire des
travaux archéologiques et sur les
cultures de toulouse dans son labo dans
son bureau et dans son discours
dissonant par rapport à la vulgate
actuel de l'histoire de l'homme
la dissonance de deux teyssandier pour s
intitule s'intituler ainsi cro magnon
n'a jamais fait la révolution
mine de rien c'est un énorme couac dans
le concept des discours sur la
préhistoire
depuis la veille breuil il y a un siècle
le paradigme préhistorique affirme qu'il
ya environ trente sept mille en cro
magnon ci-dessous trouvait le crâne de
cro magnon est arrivé en europe et c'est
qu'on est si et conduit en
révolutionnaire inventant moult
technique l'éthique ans en rupture avec
celle en vigueur depuis des dizaines de
milliers d'années baptisé le moustérien
en créant ex nihilo la technologie de
l'eau sans graves ans et en peignant
départ des caves et entend en signant là
oui bon bah en gros ils essayent de nous
dire que
même néandertal était capable de peindre
des grottes et tailler des silex
correctement ses
et c'est pas non plus la fin du monde
encore une fois c'est quelque chose donc
que tout le monde connaît que même les
scientifiques savent puisque nicolas le
t110 et le sait et qui les scientifiques
donc ils n'essayent pas de cacher la
vérité à il ne fait pas partie des
illuminati voilà et pourtant il est
scientifique ou donc une révolution
équivalente écrit henri breuil mais faut
pas non plus cité henri breuil c'était
il ya longtemps c'était un autre
contexte
c'était il ya cent ans tenant croyez
croyez les préhistoriens une simu une
simultanéité entre l'émergence de
l'homme moderne cro magnon du mois son
arrivée en europe est une révolution
culturelle et donc c'est ce que je suis
en train de dire le cro magnon aurait
amené avec lui de leur langage la pensée
et technique l'organisation sociale qui
sont les qui ont donné les nôtres
aujourd'hui est que néandertal du coup
n'avait rien de tout ça mais c'est pas
vrai néandertal il avait aussi un peu
ces trucs à lui mais il a aussi assimilé
un peu depuis l'homme de cro magnon là
pour une fois c'est de la vraie science
alors j'ai rien à des banquiers c'est
nicolas teyssandier qu'il dit donc ce
paradigme explique-t-il a survécu malgré
des signes répétés comme montrer les
fouilles des innovations des cro-magnons
les avatars plus ancien des signes le
dernier est un article dans la revue
science de vassan mourne il relate la
découverte et à 75000 hand sur le site
de blombos ce des techniques lithiques
très sophistiquée à l'aide de pressions
exercées sur la pierre préalablement
ouais mais alors la blonde bosses tu
diriges sur blombos 75 mille ans mais
lassé des sapiens à 75 mille ans en
afrique c'était déjà des sapiens 1,75
milan en france ou en europe ça aurait
été des nains ça aurait été des
néandertaliens mais lassé des sapiens
donc ça fout un peu en l'air ton
raisonnement là mon grand l'a75 milan
que les homo sapiens se comportent comme
des homo sapiens c'est pas choquant donc
préalablement chauffé instruments les
artistes solutréen des archéologues ont
découvert en europe mais aussi au proche
orient des signes gravés des ornements
des coquillages percée qui affiche
pourtant des dates allant de 90 milles à
101,45 milan bat même c'est pareil 90
mail à 45 mille ans ce sont des homo
sapiens donc on s'attend pas à ce qu'il
soit moins que dès que les homo sapiens
moderne
c'est juste que leur technologie partait
de moins loin déjà et leur culture
partait de moins loin que la nôtre
forcément il y avait 90 mille ans de
moins de technologie et de
accumulée depuis et de techniques en
orientant cro magnon sans jamais se
croiser nice influencer la période où
sur de vastes espaces européen moyen
orientaux cro magnon et néandertal au co
exister sans jamais se croiser nice
influence est difficile d'imaginer pire
situation pour la scientifique mais ta
gueule on le sait très bien que on sait
très bien que déjà il y avait que des
sapiens en afrique à cette époque les
néandertal c'était que en europe et au
moyen-orient et on sait très bien qu'ils
ont échangé des cultures et qu'ils ont
échangé des gènes alors qu'est ce que
c'est que cette façon de nous dire rien
ne le prouve et et rien ne l'interdît
lui dire va chier va chier bon il est
temps de conclure parce que la voie là
même la révolution rien à sienne ne
résiste pas à la réanalyse des documents
archéologiques qui a servi à l'inventer
lorsque l'on reprend la stratigraphie
une évolution préliminaire complètement
insensible à l'échelle de la vie humaine
à passer petit pour les hommes mais qui
efface l'idée que cro magnon arrive tout
armé de sa civilisation
oui mais bon la grotte chauvet a été
fait par des cro magnon et
et alors l'unité de cette civilisation
aurignacienne ne résisterait pas elle
non plus à l'analyse pour ne plus
précise des différentes régional affirme
teyssandier nicolas teyssandier va
jusqu'à affirmer
pire les à son empire les associations
entre outillage et fossiles humains
censé trancher les querelles de
spécialistes sur l'attribution à cro
magnon de néandertal sont rares et
souvent contestées c'est vrai pas
jusqu'à affirmer qu'il n'existe aucune
certitude associées à un contexte
archéologique des premières cultures
paléolithique supérieur entre 45 minutes
et trente cinq mille ans avec des restes
humains
indubitablement moderne bah oui oui
c'est un problème parce qu'effectivement
le l'humain arrive en europe à ce moment
là donc effectivement c'est dur de
savoir que si les restes qui sont dans
les grottes entre 45 milles et 35 milles
ans sont attribuables à néanderthal ou à
saint piat ce donc effectivement ils ont
été un peu vite attribué à sapiens quand
il était d'ailleurs moderne et un peu
vite à néanderthal quand il était
d'ailleurs entre guillemets primitive
mais bon c'est vrai que ultime en on
sait pas effectivement il n'est pas
impossible que certains des trucs qu'on
considère comme moderne appartiennent en
fait à néanderthal mais enfin des landes
airtel c'était pas un macaque
c'est le néanderthal c'est l'être humain
le plus humain de tous les humains est
un donc ce n'est pas impossible qu'il
ait été qu'il était complètement humain
dans ses comportements quoi du coup là
où le public reçoit par des écrivains
des cinéastes une histoire des relations
entre ces deux humanités qu'elle soit
celle d'une rencontre amicale ou d'un
conflit sanglant se terminant par
l'extinction de néandertal de pression
historien après avoir été peut-être trop
sur hésite les points de vue radicaux de
josé braga en rupture et nicolas
teyssandier en rupture avec le discours
tenu par d'autres préhistorien comme
jean jacques hublin sont ils un retour
en arrière banon on corrige les erreurs
qu'on a fait dans le passé les
attributions trop rapide aux conceptions
prévalente avant la génétique
moléculaire vienne mettre son grain de
sel dans la sphère je ne vois pas ce que
aux conceptions prévalant avant que la
génétique moléculaire bien
ça ne veut rien dire rudimentaire dans
ses premières approches elle a tout
d'abord inventé la fameuse eve africaine
puis un adam tout aussi mythique est la
mise en scène mais laisse adam et eve
génétique en dehors de ça c'est une tout
autre question la dent et f génétique
elle a mis en scène la sortie d'afrique
d'un homo sapiens et façon violemment ou
non toutes autres populations de nos
origines pour enfin déniché une part de
néandertaliens en nous ce qui suppose de
renverser la barrière mais auparavant
entre l'homme moderne et cette humanité
non elle a toujours été discutée le
l'éternel débat entre sapiens sapiens
sapiens neanderthalensis il a toujours
existé ce débat donc ça va pas renverser
une vieille barrière à ce stade il
serait surtout imprudent de conclure et
voilà et tout ça pour en revenir aux
reptilien du coup et comme le remarque
un commentateur il est difficile de
faire accepter que quand honda annonce
au carbone 14 en date que l'os est pas
forcément les outils qui l'accompagnent
match 2018 mais en dehors de ces études
ci dessus des découvertes de crâne
allongé naturel ou artificiellement
imitation ou deux où l'espèce supérieur
à des théories reptilienne quels sont
les autres données en voici des exemples
dinosauriens et voyages temporels les
grilles et la théorie dinosaur yens
science fait histoire donc auto citation
hommes et dinosaures les faits sont
têtus
ces espèces fantômes qui entre notre adn
et bah ouais comme je disais là sur ce
site là il ya vraiment du matos pour en
faire un paquet de des bonnes kg
pénitence là je vais faire pénitence
mais grave
avec ce truc bon le figaro
éventuellement ces espèces fantômes qui
entre qui hantent notre adn le titre à
la limite et un peu plus ta clique mais
on voit bien qu'en gros ça fait
référence aux découvertes récentes de
l'adn qui sont certainement issus de
croisements avec d'autres sous-espèces
humaine en gros mais dont on dont on ne
sait pas exactement lesquels donc
denisova typiquement voilà
bref on arrive à la fin on arrive à la
fin ça vous allez finition en apothéose
les découvertes faites entre 2015 et
2018 par des oies queiros péruvien
[ __ ] de merde
il me poursuivent à l'émoi quiros perry
vient de ne pas le pana ce cas la sphère
des momies de nascar à [ __ ] les
découvertes faites entre 2015 et 2018
par les oies quiros péruvien du côté de
pas le pana ce cas à faire des momies
nasca et dont la presse s'est faite en
dehors du pérou assez discrète
tu rigoles s'est passé sur iphone kings
love sayan ce que je veux dire c'est un
retentissement international va chier
c'est juste que c'est ça c'est fait ça
s'est fait rapidement fermer sa gueule
parce que c'est de la merde c'est
surtout ça pour et elle en fait confirmé
l'existence de cette descendance d'une
espèce de dinosaure évolué il ya encore
quelques siècles voire encore de nous de
nos jours cacher un dossier très complet
sur ces découvertes en attente d'autres
résultats de l'analyse mais dont les
premières ça c'est le sas et la parole
magique et quand on leur dit mais non ça
c'est pas des momies ses enfants quand
on leur dit que mais non en fait ça
c'est une momie humaine qu'on a mutilé
nous disent n'en faut attendre plus d
analyse non mais ça c'est un crâne de
chacon a mutilé nord mais il faut
attendre plus d analyse voilà et à
chaque fois qu'une nouvelle analyse
arrive on leur dit vous voyez bien que
votre analyse allemande que c'est de la
merde votre mamie n'en faut attendre
plus d analyse ça c'est là ça aussi
c'est encore ça fait partie de la sainte
trinité de la pseudo science qui sait
qu'il faut toujours attendre plus des
analyses mais dans les premières
expertises par les scientifique péruvien
mexicains américains canadiens et russes
dont certains renommée web enfin pas
pour les bonnes raisons
reconnu et très diplômés très diplômés
c'est un argument d'autorité étonne ses
scientifiques dont certains sceptiques
dont certains très sceptique avant
certains résultats science fait et
histoire les reliques du pérou je ne
cliqueraient pas sur ce lien allez vous
faire [ __ ]
voilà bah si vous voulez en savoir plus
justement sur ces mots me menace cas je
vous renvoie aussi d'irna
alors elle a remis récemment la vidéo de
gollum illuminati qui à mon sens pouvait
définitivement que toute cette affaire
santé le gaz voilà donc toutes les
vidéos de gollum
donc il a analysé les images de la momie
maria golo me luminati et il a trouvé un
truc très intéressant voilà donc la
momie de maria à la 3 doit donc je
rappelle l'argument le fait qu'ils ont
trois doigts c'est ça qui leur fait dire
que c'est des reptiliens
parce que pourrait évidemment il y avait
que les dinosaures théropodes du genre
du trot dont justement qu'il n'avait que
trois doigts or c'est pas vrai les
rhinocéros son sillon trois doigts alors
pourquoi il préfère la théorie
reptilienne sur la théorie du rhinocéros
moi je crois que je vais fonder ma
propre religion donc la théorie la
religion des reptiliens rhinocéros dans
des rhinocéros indien du coup ça sera
pas les reptiliens rhinocéros dont c'est
l'airé c'est les rhinocéros siens du
passé qui vivait au milieu scène et ils
n'ont pas disparu en fait ils ont ils
sont devenus super intelligent donc
c'est devenu des rhinocéros intelligents
ils ont une corne sur le nez et même
qu'on retrouve des crânes humains avec
des cornes sur le nez d'abord parce que
je les dis mais on nous les a volés
parce que c'est les méchants
scientifiques ils veulent pas qu'on
sache qu'ils avaient des rhinocéros
intelligent donc voila c'était en fait
maria c'est un rhinocéros intelligent
femelle parce qu'elle n'a pas de cornes
sur son nez et du coup elle a trois
doigts comme un rhinocéros
voilà donc donc non 7
il faut savoir que les dinosaures
notamment au niveau de l'anatomie de la
cheville je vais vous montrer une
cheville de dinosaures donc la cheville
d'un dinosaure elle est ultra simplifié
en fait donc ce voilà ça c'est une
donc dans une cheville normalement vous
avez tout un tas d'os mis un peu en
bordel et ça vous donne une articulation
qui peut aller de gauche à droite de
haut en bas et d'avant en arrière en
gros et ça c'est la cheville d'un
dinosaure
donc vous voyez peut-être pas forcément
la différence mais ce trait là il est
très important parce que c'est la seule
articulation qui a dans la cheville
c'est à dire que les eaux sont organisés
de telle façon sont très très bien
organisée complètement aligner de telle
façon à ce qu'il ait qu'une articulation
qui permet du sein à la cheville
simplement d'aller en avant en arrière
donc voilà ce que ça donne donc ici vous
avez les doigts donc ça c'est un pied de
t-rex donc voilà ce que ça donne vous
avez ici les trois doigts vous avez ici
les métacarpe
et là vous avez le bas du tibia avec les
au final man 2 le de la cheville
tous les os de la cheville vous voyez
sont tous concentrés là et vous voyez
entre les deux l'articulation donc
l'articulation est extrêmement simple et
tous les os de la cheville sont
fusionnés donc ça c'est typiquement ce
qu'on trouve chez les dinosaures et là
ce qu'on trouve chez maria déjà de base
c'est pas ça du tout c'est alors il ya
d'autres images vous allez sur le site
de la lienne project directement vous
regardez les images de la cheville de
maria et vous verrez que c'est un beau
bordel comme chez un humain parce que
c'est typiquement une cheville humaine
en fait qu'elle à marjah c'est pas du
tout une cheville dinosaur yens et donc
ça ça c'est un caractère aussi qui est
très conserver chez les dinosaures
cette morphologie de la cheville
puisqu'on le retrouve aussi chez les
oiseaux regardez un oiseau vous verrez
l'astragale est complètement fusionné au
tibia et vous verrez ces trois aulas
sont même encore plus fusionner chez les
oiseaux et ça ne forment plus qu'un seul
os donc ça c'est un caractère qui est
très dinosauriens donc si mariah était
descendante d'un dinosauriens bas on le
verrait sur ces mets ta carte
on le verrait sur ces métatarse pardon
et on verrait aussi sur ses métacarpe du
coup puisque j'en parle on verrait sur
ces mets ta carte qu'il ya un os semi
lunaire parce que trop dont avait un os
semi lunaire donc si je tape smi l'une
est bonne voilà les oiseaux ont un os
mais enfin les oiseaux et les
troodontidés et les dinosaures manière
apte orient en général ont un petit os
ici qui s'appelle le semis lunaire je
vous mets au défi de trouver ce semi
lunaire chez maria voilà il n'y est pas
cherchez pas spoiler alert il n'y est
pas et dans ce qui est très intéressant
avec gollum inhumain la vidéo de gollum
illuminati c'est qu'il montre que cette
momie maria à trois doigts mais qu'elle
a un deux trois quatre ligaments donc il
ya bien un doigt qui a été arraché et
donc la fin sachant que ses ligaments
s'ils voulaient couper alors que la
momie f
alors que la personne est vivante ou
fraîchement décédé
ils vont immédiatement se rétracter dans
l'avant-bras donc ils seront plus
visibles là dans la sueur la main sur le
dos de la main ça veut dire que ses
ligaments n'ont pas été coupés de frais
ils n'ont pas été coupés quand là quand
la personne était vivant tout
fraîchement décédé ils ont été coupées
une fois que le ligament était momifié
donc il s'agit bien d'une mutilation de
mots me voilà donc gollum illuminati
grâce à cette vidéo nous montre et bien
que maria est définitivement un faux
voilà donc merci gollum illuminati
d'avoir mis cette vidéo là en ligne donc
science fait histoire j'ai envie de
conclure mon cul merci à tous et à la
prochaine fois